So Leute, ups, ich sollte mir vielleicht mal mein Headset auch richtig aufsetzen.
Ich bin am Start.
Ja, also ich meine, im Titel steht zwar Geburtstagsstream, das stimmt auch, aber wir werden nichts Besonderes als Geburtstagsstream machen.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt nochmal kurz ausprobieren muss, ist, ob mein WeepTTS auch CuteChat sagen kann.
CuteChat, ach ne.
Warum crasht das? Warum crasht das, wenn ich das umstelle? Das habe ich doch irgendwie kackeprogrammiert wieder.
RIP.
Warum crasht das, wenn ich, vielleicht habe ich da irgendwie einen Bug, dass ich das zusammenschreiben muss oder so.
CuteChat, CuteChat.
Was? Was? Moment, was?
Das passt.
CuteChat, CuteChat.
Ja, das ist gut.
CuteChat, Prime, Subscriber.
You got to made it. You got, you got to made it.
So, hau jetzt zu.
Zweimal U.
Moment, du meinst so hier?
Nein, das funktioniert nicht.
Der Sebaro ist wieder da.
Der CuteChat hatte ich schon vermisst das letzte Mal. Da hat jeder alle fünf Minuten gefragt, wo ist denn der Sebaro?
Ja, funktioniert am besten.
Ja, Leute.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe es in den Streamtitel geschrieben, Geburtstag und so.
Aber wir machen heute nichts irgendwie Birthday-mäßiges.
Ja, ich meine, wozu?
Und, äh, irgendwie hat es den ein bisschen verschoben. Kann das sein? War der nicht eben da?
Oh, 500 Bits. Dankeschön.
Pock, BigBrainChat heute wieder.
Ähm, ja, wie, also, wir machen heute nichts großartig Birthday-mäßiges.
Wir basteln weiter an unserer Paketverfolgungs-App.
Heute.
Heute werden wir, ähm, ein paar Sachen ausprobieren, unter anderem Browser fernsteuern, Chrome fernsteuern mit .NET und vielleicht probieren wir die UPS-API noch aus.
Also, wir probieren heute aus, ob wir es schaffen, aus unserem .NET-Programm einen Chrome fernzusteuern, allerdings einen Headless-Chrome, also sprich, ähm, genau, Desmond, so sieht es aus, der kennt sich aus, der weiß Bescheid.
Ähm.
Und, da muss natürlich Headless sein, also wir wollen den Chrome ja nicht sehen.
Das wäre sonst irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig.
Habe ich noch nicht gemacht, aus .NET raus, die offizielle, die offizielle, äh, Library ist, äh, Node.
Node.js ist das, das ist das hier.
Hat, äh, nur 52.000 GitHub-Sterne.
Ähm, das ist quasi die offizielle, äh, offizielle, von, von Chrome-API zum, ähm, Chrome-Remote.
Und, fernzusteuern, was sagen sie denn selbst?
Sie sagen hier, Headless-Chrome-API, ja, genau.
Und, die gibt es allerdings auch, gibt es, da gibt es allerdings auch eine .NET-Version, habe ich gesehen.
Und, die probieren wir mal aus, denn, für unser Paket-Tracking, ja, hier, Puppeteer-Sharp, die wir brauchen, ähm, weil, um unser, um unsere, unser Paket-Tracking zu machen, ich meine, wir haben eine API von DHL und wir haben eine API von DPD und wir haben eine API von UPS.
Mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Von Hermos haben wir schon mal gar keinen und von Amazon auch nicht.
Das heißt, wir werden auf jeden Fall ein paar Webseiten parsen müssen, da kommen wir nicht, kommen wir nicht drum herum.
Und, ich hätte auch gerne so einen, so einen Fallback-Tracking, also sprich, sollten irgendwie die API-Aufrufe aus, aufgebraucht sein für DHL oder sollte DHL oder irgendein anderer Anbieter was an seiner Seite geändert haben, an seiner API geändert haben, dass es dann, dass, dass man so eine, eine Fallback-Seite für Tracking hat.
Und, was es dafür gibt, ist hier, so ein, so.
So eine China, so eine, ich glaube, das ist eine, ich glaube, das ist eine China-Seite.
Da kann man hier seine, seine Pakete eingeben.
Ich such mal kurz raus, ich hatte das letzte Mal auch welche.
Hier zum Beispiel hat mir letztens jemand eine Hermos, eine Hermos-Paketnummer gegeben.
Und, da sagt er not found, ähm, multiple, oder was, DPD, war es gar kein Hermos?
Okay, äh, kann, kann der überhaupt Hermos?
Ja, ja, Hermos.
Hermos.
Man gucken, hat mir eigentlich einer, hat mir letztens im Stream einer, eine, eine,
zum Test eine Trackingnummer von Hermos gegeben.
Okay, der trackt sich, der trackt sich da kaputt.
Dann probieren wir das jetzt nochmal mit DPD aus.
Ich hab auch noch ein DPD-Paket hier.
DPD, DPD.
Ja doch, hier, guck hier, Hermos Germany.
So, und, ähm, die Seite hätte ich gerne als Fallback und vielleicht verwenden wir die
auch für sowas wie Hermos, die halt selbst keine API anbieten und Pakete.
Paketen zu verfolgen. Es ist relativ
armselig irgendwie. Also armselig
anführungsstrich. Also ich meine,
es ist denen ihr gutes Recht zu sagen,
sie bieten keine API an. Aber ich meine,
warum nicht? Die haben die Tracking-Informationen
eh. Es ist besser,
die bieten offizielle API an, als wie das die Leute
mit irgendwie komischen Webseiten-Parsing
rumhantieren müssen.
Brauchst du noch einen DHL-Sendungscode?
Ja, kann nichts schaden.
Kann nichts schaden.
Ich brauche viele Testing-Codes.
Aber wenn dann
soweit sind, auch mal ein paar Testing-Codes,
wo man hier so einen Zwischenschritt
testen kann. Übrigens, die
Sprache müssen wir dann umstellen. Nicht auf Deutsch,
sondern auf Englisch,
falls das funktioniert.
Genau.
Und die Webseite müssen wir irgendwie
parsen.
Heute Frankfurt Vollsperrung.
Angeblich war das, weil
irgendwelche Leute am Hauptbahnhof
angeblich
hat die Polizei Frankfurt gesagt,
die Sperrung am Hauptbahnhof war
weil irgendwelche Leute Schließfächer
aufgebrochen haben und abgehauen sind.
DHL.
Oh, nice, danke.
Leute, irgendwelche Schließfächer am Hauptbahnhof aufgebrochen haben.
Wir können doch gerade mal gucken.
Twitter, Polizei, Frankfurt.
Und
es gab wohl irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht, ob es...
Müssen wir mal lesen. Ich glaube, ich habe gelesen,
es gab einen Schusswechsel zwischen Polizei
und den Dudes.
Nee, die Polizei hat geschossen.
Es gab keinen Schusswechsel, sondern
wahrscheinlich,
irgendwelche Warnschüsse oder um die Typen
zu erwischen, keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Das war heute in Frankfurt.
Hatten sich an einer Bank am Bahnhof
unerlaubt
Zugriff auf Schließfächer verschafft.
Also im Prinzip ein Banküberfall.
Wenn man es so will.
Können Sie mal den offiziellen Report angucken.
Heute Nachmittag gegen 5 Uhr kam es
auf der Düsseldorfer Straße. Das ist wirklich
direkt, das ist die Straße direkt
über dem Hauptbahnhof, die Düsseldorfer Straße.
Das ist, ähm,
das ist das, was quasi angrenzt am Hauptbahnhof.
Da ist der Hauptbahnhof
und da ist die Düssel...
Da, hier.
Da ist der Hauptbahnhof und da ist die Düsseldorfer Straße.
Also sprich, das geht wirklich
direkt, das ist das, was direkt am Hauptbahnhof
vorbeigeht.
Ja, und irgendwo da haben sie eine Bank
überfallen anscheinend.
Mehrere Personen, ich mach mal ein bisschen
größer, was war denn hier? Mehrere Personen hatten sich
in der Bank unerlaubt Zugriff
auf Schließfächer verschafft und dabei den Alarm
ausgerüstet.
Scheinen jetzt nicht die, äh, Big Brains
den Banküberfall-Leute
gewesen zu sein. Anschließend
flüchten sie in einem Fahrzeug in Richtung
Hauptbahnhof. Moment.
Da hätten wir dann wahrscheinlich zu Fuß schneller
gewesen. Das ist ja direkt um die Ecke.
Ähm, drei Männer wurden mittlerweile festgenommen.
Die Fahndung nach weiteren Personen bleibt
weiterhin bestehen. Zu Beginn der
Flucht kam es zu einer Schussabgabe seitens der
Polizei. Dabei wurde zufolge niemand
verletzt.
Wobei man mal sagen muss, wenn eine Bank überfällt,
ähm, da muss man mit Rechnen auch verletzt sein.
Der öffentliche
Person war zwischenzeitlich, ah ja, das war
komplett gesperrt. Komplett
durch. Alles. Also,
ging gar nichts mehr an der Ecke.
Okay, mehr gibt's nicht. Ist kurz, kurz
und knackig, ne? Ja, das
war heute. Banküberfall. Frankfurt.
Ich sag doch, in Frankfurt geht's in letzter Zeit übelst ab.
Vor allem
hast du in Frankfurt immer mehr Gestörte unterwegs.
Immer mehr Gestörte.
Immer mehr Drogen, na gut,
Drogenabhängige vielleicht jetzt, vielleicht nicht
mehr, aber immer noch auf ausreichend
einem Niveau, ja? Mehr braucht man
davon nicht.
Oceans 12. Ne, ich glaube
nicht, dass ich das auch nur ansatzweise
auf das, weil, also am Hauptbahnhof
war eher Oceans 420
war da angesagt.
Wenn ich mir die Leute anguck.
Ohne 420 hätten die sich wahrscheinlich
gar nicht getraut, die Bank zu überfallen.
Zum Glück
hat mich mein Chef
heimgefahren. Alter, hast du, hast du Glück,
dass du einen netten Chef hast.
Du bist nicht zufällig 25.
Du bist nicht zufällig 25 weiblich und siehst gut aus.
Dann würde ich mir Gedanken machen, warum dich dein Chef heimgefahren hat.
Aber wenn
dich dein Chef einfach so eingefahren hat, ist dein Chef
wahrscheinlich einfach nett.
Ach, Sibaro, das ist praktisch, ja.
Ach hier, Tosiki, 24
Hermes Code. Brauchen wir auch noch.
Jawohl, schreibe ich mir auf. Dankeschön.
Ich kann nur Codes benutzen, die
innerhalb der letzten 120 Tage
verschickt wurden zum Testen,
weil danach schmeißen die ganzen Anbieter
ihre Sachen weg.
Halbes Kriegsgebiet
in Frankfurt. Ohne Scheiß.
In letzter Zeit
ist da echt
was los, ja.
Also manchmal hast du echt Bedenken,
da langzulaufen.
Liga extrem.
Wer weiß, wer weiß.
Vielleicht gefällt das auch deinem Chef.
In der heutigen Zeit ist das ja alles
kein Problem.
Aber ich vermute mal, dein Chef ist einfach nur nett.
DHL Code
XXX
schreibe ich mir auch noch auf.
Also DHL Tracking nochmal
habe ich jetzt.
Eine Menge.
Woran liegt es denn?
Das sind Frankfurt.
Schwer gute Frage, woran das liegt.
Also es ist merkwürdig in Frankfurt.
Na also es ist prinzipiell so viel,
also Bahnhof und um Hauptbahnhof und so.
Ist so viel, so viel Bahn Security.
Wie noch nie eigentlich unterwegs und auch Polizei
ist relativ viel in Frankfurt Frankfurt unterwegs.
Wir sagen einfach, dass die.
Das generell die Gewaltbereitschaft der Leute höher ist als früher.
Ähm.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich sein, ja.
Ja, Maske 95, das spielt er auf jeden Fall mit rein.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ähm.
Und was auch mit rein spielt ist,
dass sich die Art der Drogen, die sich die Leute am Hauptbahnhof reinhauen, geändert hat, ja.
Also früher haben die sich, früher hast du dann oftmals einen zwischen zwei Autos sitzen sehen.
Der hat sich immer sein, was war denn das wohl?
Der hat sich Heroin oder so auf seiner Fanta-Dose aufgewärmt.
Das hast du früher immer gesehen, das.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wozu Fanta-Dosen alles gut sind, bevor ich regelmäßig nach Frankfurt gefahren bin.
Da haben die sich früher immer ihre, haben sie sich früher immer die Dosen aus dem Mülleimer geholt und haben die aufgeschnitten.
Und haben sich dann irgendwo in die Ecke gesetzt und quasi auf der Dose umgedreht.
Dann so ein Feuerchen unter der Dose gemacht.
Das ist dann so ein Mini-Kamin quasi, wenn du das richtig machst in der Dose.
Und haben dann oben drauf ihr Zeug gekocht und aufgezogen.
So, und das, das, das in Anführungsstrichen Schöne daran, das war absolut Big Brain, also was das angeht, waren die echt, waren die echt erfinderisch, ne.
Ähm, ja, und das in Anführungsstrichen Schöne daran war, dass die nicht aggressiv waren, die waren, oder selten aggressiv waren.
Die waren einfach nur fertig mit der Welt.
Die haben einfach nur rumgehongen den ganzen Tag.
Und das, das Beste, was die irgendwie rausgekriegt haben, wenn du vorbeigelaufen bist, war mal irgendwie...
Oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Mehr, mehr, mehr ging da im Endeffekt nicht.
So, und mittlerweile ist, siehst halt kaum noch Leute da, die sich irgendwie Heroin spritzen.
Das, das, das, das Heftigste, was bei, vor ein paar Jahren war mal, da ist bei uns, äh, also direkt schräg gegenüber, auf einer Straße weiter vom Hauptbahnhof, ist so ein, so ein Wäschesalon.
Da ist das halt so, weißt du, so mit öffentlichen Waschmaschinen und sowas.
Und da standen die halt mittags, während die in ihre, während die auf ihre Wäsche gewartet haben.
Ja, ich mein, auch Drogenabhängige müssen ihre Wäsche waschen.
Äh, standen die dort in der Tür, haben dich angegrinst.
Und du hast so gedacht, hä, der guckt da aber schon komisch.
Und da hast du gesehen, da hat er eine Spritze im Arm hängen.
Das war, das war so, das war so dieser Anblick, das war für mich so Frankfurt pur, ja.
Da hast du so, oh, fuck, geh weg, ey, was ist da los?
Ja, und, ähm, ich glaube, das trägt auch dazu bei, dass es heute, gefühlt zumindest so, wie man, wie man das beobachten kann.
Ähm, weniger Heroinabhängige gibt es in Frankfurt, sondern die rauchen alle irgendwas.
Und ich glaube, das Zeug, was die sich da reinpfeifen heute und was die da heute, ähm, sich reinhauen, macht die Leute, glaube ich, aggressiver als Heroin.
Aber die Polizeistatistik soll wohl sagen, Heroin kostet, ja, das hat alles, oh, kann schon sein, kann schon sein.
Aber ich sehe sehr, ich sehe viel weniger als früher welche, die sich was spritzen, sondern die rauchen alle irgendwas.
Und ich glaube, das macht, also das, was auch immer die da rauchen, macht die Leute...
...macht die Leute aggressiver als früher.
Das ist bestimmt Krokodil.
War Krokodil nicht dieses komische, russisch zusammengemischte Hinterhof-Drogen-Zeug?
Wie lange lebst du schon in Frankfurt?
Ich lebe ja nicht direkt in Frankfurt, ich wohne ein bisschen, ich wohne ein bisschen nebendran.
Aber ich fahre schon seit, also ich, regelmäßig, auf die Arbeit fahre ich da seit, wo liegen sie, seit 2015?
Ah, nicht ganz 15 Jahre.
Nicht ganz.
Seit 2007 ungefähr.
Bisschen, bisschen.
Früher schon, aber ich bin, ich bin früher auch immer regelmäßig in Frankfurt gewesen, das ist einfach die, die größte, die größte Stadt in der Nähe, da ist auch im Prinzip immer was los, du kriegst alles mögliche, also nicht das, was jetzt, wenn, wenn ich das so sage, vorerst eine halbe, eine halbe Stunde, ja, fast meintal, fast meintal, ja.
Willst du sagen, du kriegst halt alle möglichen Sachen, die du, die du brauchst, ja, sei es von Hardware oder sei es eigentlich nur, eigentlich nur was, was Snackeria machen, ja.
Und ich glaube, es liegt daran, dass die Leute heute aggressiver sind als früher an dem, was sie sich reinhauen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt, vor ein paar Jahren, äh, nicht vor ein paar Jahren, man zählt für den Scheiß, ähm, vor ein paar Tagen, das war ja ganz groß in der Presse, da haben sich ja alle drüber ausgelassen, dass ein, äh, mittlerweile weiß man es ja, ein, dass man das jetzt zusammenkriege, ein,
ähm, jemand aus Eritrea, also aus Afrika, der in der Schweiz gelebt hat und illegal, also da quasi in der, aus der Schweiz abgehauen ist, weil sie,
ähm, ihn gesucht haben, hatte er in Frankfurt Frau plus Kinder von, von Zug geschmissen, das ging ja, ging ja komplett, ging ja komplett durch die Presse, das haben wahrscheinlich alle mehr oder weniger mitgekriegt, also in Frankfurt ist in letzter Zeit wirklich was los, da geht's, da geht's echt ab und, ähm, was ja auch geil ist, ne, dann, das, die, die logische, also, die Big Brain Konsequenz, die sie jetzt daraus ziehen wollen, ist ja, ähm, Barrieren am Bahnsteig aufzustellen,
ähm,
dass ich mir gedacht hab, wär's nicht vielleicht sinnvoller, irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass Leute nicht vor den Zug geschmissen werden, anstatt jetzt Barrieren aufzustellen, dass Leute nicht mehr so einfach vor den Zug geworfen werden können, das klingt für mich irgendwie voll abstruso, wenn ich mir das so, wenn ich mir das so anhöre, ja, the fuck, ich hatte noch nie Bedenken, dass mich irgendjemand vor den Zug wirft, so vielleicht jetzt, ja, naja, das ist, das ist echt,
irgendwie,
irgendwie verkehrt rum, ja, man sollte doch dafür sorgen, dass das, dass das nicht vorkommt und nicht, dass es schwieriger ist, das versteh ich nicht so genau, also, das leuchtet mir nicht ein, Frankfurt ist in Deutschland auch die Stadt, wo viele den American Dream suchen, naja, gut, ähm, was Banken angeht, gibt's ja in, gibt's ja nicht viel Vergleichbares in Deutschland oder in Europa, hast du, warst du schon mal bei Held der Steine, nein, aber ich hab den letztens gesehen, der ist mir letztens entgegengelassen,
ich dachte mir so, ding, ding, ähm, wie ich zum Südbahnhof, natürlich, den hast, den kennst du doch, den hast du schon mal irgendwo gesehen und da hab ich dann drüber nachgedacht, da hab ich mir gedacht, das, das war 100% der Held der Steine, äh, ja, das ist Baro, das stimmt, das muss ich eben machen, im, das mach ich vor dem Stream, wo wir das mit dem E-Mail-Scanner ausprobieren, äh, Clocks Royal Mail will ich eigentlich nicht einbauen zum Tracken, naja, gut, ich würd sagen, da fangen wir mal an, ähm, so, Visual Studio aufmachen, ach so, wisst ihr, was wir auch machen wollen, äh, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ähm, wir könnten uns auch, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon gesehen habt, also ich hab's nicht gesehen, aber ich hab gesehen, dass es das gibt, wir könnten uns mal ein bisschen Ausschnitt vom, äh, von Modern Warfare Gameplay angucken, da gab's wohl gestern einen Stream, wo sie das gezeigt haben, ich hab mir noch nichts davon angeguckt, gar nichts, ich hab nur auf Twitter gelesen, ich hab nur auf Twitter gelesen, dass, ähm, es wohl verhältnismäßig gut ausschaut und es keine Minimap gibt, aber eine Konsolen-App, Konsolen-App geht immer,
volle drei Stunden angucken, hä, drei, ich, ich kann mir keine drei Stunden COD angucken, ich hab schon, ich, ich, ich deinstalliere schon COD nach drei Stunden Spielen,
drei Stunden Video, wobei Video, äh, COD, Video angucken ist nicht so belastend wie, äh, selber spielen, so, wir sind schon bei Konsolen-App 12, das passt natürlich, wir sind ja hier die Konsolen-App-Helden schlechthin letzter Zeit,
ups, was mach ich denn da, Press,
Any Key to Exit, warum gibt's eigentlich als Makro nicht CR für Konsol-Readline, ich mein, ich weiß, dass ich mir's anlegen kann, aber warum ist das nicht standardmäßig drin, das ist doch, wäre doch pock, wenn das dabei wär,
was, Metallica hat einen COD-Trailer gemacht, oder meinst du einen neuen Trailer für irgendwas von Metallica, also jetzt nicht irgendwie mit, was mit COD was zu tun hat, Metallica ist im Trailer, na gut, die haben ja alles mögliche schon durch, ja,
ja, dann gucken wir uns mal an,
gucken wir uns mal an, also wenn Metallica im Trailer ist, dann müssen wir uns das mal angucken, COD, vor 23 Stunden,
die, die, die, oh, pock-Musik, hoff ich mach's nicht zu laut, äh, Moment, das ist gar kein Trailer, ja, das ist eindeutig interessant, man, aber wo ist, wo ist der Trailer, ja, ne, Reveal-Song, Trailer-Song, ja, danke, Flamers,
Reveal, okay, mal MV Reveal,
Reveal, machen wir hier mal, das da, ha, sagt mir überhaupt das Richtige, der Richtige ist, ich hab, ah, da, ich hab einen Link gepostet, okay, da ist das der Richtige, also, was mich schon mal sehr zuversichtlich macht, ist das hier, okay, gucken wir mal, mich verwirrt's ja immer noch, dass das einfach, einfach nur Modern Warfare heißt, wo ist der Hund, wo ist der Hund, ich hab gehofft, der Hund kommt wieder,
die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Grills auch dabei,
Es sieht aus wie COD.
Am wenigsten haben sie gute Musik drunter.
Nein, das ist Enter Sandman, eindeutig.
Sie fängt ja gar nicht an rumzuschreien, aber gut.
Hat ein bisschen was von Rainbow Six.
Huge Singing Skill.
Juggernaut.
Moment.
Was, was, was? Operation?
Ist das jetzt ein Singleplayer-Trailer?
Ne, Multiplayer-Trailer.
Was stand da eben von Operation?
Operation?
Der Name erinnert mich voll an Battlefield.
Operation...
Krasna Raid?
Was sonst?
Wenn uns nichts mehr einfällt, ist mal wieder in Russland Invasion angesagt.
So, wie viel Granaten konnte er tut grad schmeißen?
Ah, ne, nur einer.
Ist das der Panzer?
Oh, das ist Killstreak. Wahrscheinlich ist es Killstreak.
Also Tank Drop, Killstreak oder sowas.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ach, der... was macht... Moment.
Der steckt im Holz drin, oder?
Ich dachte, deswegen sieht das auch so merkwürdig aus.
Der Trailer ist nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Feuerschnelles Verordern und frühes Zugang zur offenen Beta.
Voraufsatz und Zugang zur offenen Beta.
Von der offenen Beta auf den offenen.
Dann haben Sie n...
Wo haben Sie die Sprecher immer her? Die hören sich immer alle exakt gleich an.
Warum muss ich überhaupt... warum muss... Moment.
Jetzt hab ich mich erst über den Sprecher lustig gemacht.
Ich muss mir mal Gedanken über den Inhalt machen.
Warum...
Warum muss ich pre-ordern, um Zugang zur Open Beta zu kriegen?
Das ist Activision 900 IQ, ey.
Moment.
Das kam was.
Ja, auch.
Ah, Early Access.
Ah, ja, ah, ja, ja.
Okay.
Das ist, das ist, das ist die übliche Geschichte, dass er zwei Tage früher spielen darf, sowas.
Äh, bringt mir eh nix, weil First on PS4 hab ich keinen Bock.
First on Xbox hätte ich ehrlich gesagt mehr Bock, aber am liebsten wär mir eigentlich auf allen Plattformen gleichzeitig.
Ähm, weil, das liegt bei mir einfach daran, ich kann mit dem Playstation-Controller nicht spielen gescheit.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Also, ich kann sowas wie Uncharted oder so spielen.
Aber was, wo es drauf ankommt, dass man schnell und ordentlich ziehen kann.
Ich krieg's, ich krieg das mit dem, ich, ich hab nicht, meine Hände sind nicht Playstation-Controller-kompatibel.
Xbox-Controller, kein Problem.
Den verwende ich auch immer noch am PC, wenn man irgendwie Assassin's Creed spielen will oder so.
Aber, ich, meine Hände sind nicht PS, Playstation, Dualshock-kompatibel.
Ich weiß, ich hab so einen Adapter.
Ey, Boss ist back.
Ich hab so einen, so einen Xbox auf Playstation-Adapter.
Also, ich könnte es damit theoretisch spielen.
Access to the open beta.
Open beta.
Okay, hier gibt's Multiplayer.
Ach, leck mich, äh, ist das jetzt euer Ernst?
Als spielt irgendjemand, der 18 ist, dieses Game, das spielen, die, die, also, das spielen 60, 70, 80% Leute, die noch nicht in dem Alter sind.
Naja, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen Progress machen.
Können wir uns dann, Shroud 6 und 6.
Okay, dann haben sie wenigstens mal einen, der ordentlich spielen kann, ey.
Die Typen, die sie bei diesem 2 und 2 Modus haben.
Das war ja, das war ja nix, ne?
Shroud kann wenigstens spielen.
Und wahrscheinlich besser als die meisten, die auf diesem COD-Event hocken.
PC Master Race.
Was sonst?
Okay, erstmal 3 Stunden Waffenauswahl.
Okay, wann geht's ins Game hier?
Keine Minimap, keine Minimap.
Multiplayer, Premiere, 6 und 6.
Das ist nicht, das ist 6 und 6 Domination.
Würde ich sagen.
All my settings are not right.
Ja gut, Shroud hat aufs Maul bekommen.
Jeder kriegt den COD aufs Maul.
Und wenn du das Game nicht kennst, ist es für alle erstmal gleich.
Aber Shroud ist jemand, der spielt das Game 5 Stunden.
Und jemand anderes spielt das Game 5 Stunden.
Und er ist einfach mal doppelt so gut.
Oh mein Gott, das Zoom ist insane.
Cryzak.
Habe ich das richtig ausgerufen?
Cryzak 583 Twitch Prime Sub.
Dankeschön, nice.
Ich habe jetzt übrigens ein neues.
Ich habe jetzt extra dafür.
Extra dafür habe ich ein neues.
Einen neuen Sound.
Ach Moment, es ist gar kein Prime Subscriber.
Egal, trotzdem nice.
Kamass, naja.
Wie spricht man es denn richtig aus?
Cryzak?
CrySC?
Oh, jetzt wird erstmal hier der Hardscope rausgeholt.
Da ist ja schon mal vorbei.
Die müssten mal einen COD machen ohne Sniper.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Okay Leute, ich glaube, wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an.
Ich meine, ich bin hier in der Science & Technology Kategorie.
Und außerdem wollte ich ein bisschen Progress machen.
Weil irgendwie fühle ich mich gerade in der Lage, ordentlich Progress zu machen.
Weil ich fühle mich gerade in der Lage, mich konzentrieren zu können.
Deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal Progress machen.
Und wir gucken uns dann morgen einfach mal, da stelle ich mal die Kategorie auf COD um oder so.
Da gucken wir uns morgen mal die...
Das geht das Gameplay an und ich gebe meinen Senf dazu ab.
Aber, während wir jetzt anfangen, müssen wir mal hier...
Stimmt, besserer Qualität als die Uralt-Aufnahmen.
Ein übelst nicer Song ist das.
Bist du heute 34 geworden?
Nein!
Das ist eigentlich lustig.
Irgendwie, das haben alle was geschrieben von wegen hier, vieles Birthday, mein Geburtstag, alles gut.
Es hat mich keiner gefragt, wie alt ich geworden bin.
Außer, dass ich bei H.O. jetzt...
Ich hab 50, 50 hab ich gelesen.
50 hat jemand geschrieben.
34 hat jemand geschrieben.
Ich mein, ich hab schon ein paar Mal im Stream gesagt, ne.
420, 69.
Ja, was ist die Sache? Das kann alles sein.
Ne, 35.
35 bin ich geworden.
35.
Metal, genau.
Ein Sub!
Super, Kobi10, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Moment, Moment, das hat man jetzt nicht gehört.
Wartet mal, ich hab ne Idee, was wir jetzt machen.
Passt nämlich ganz gut.
Hä? So geht das, richtig.
Hehehe.
Till the 70 comes.
Sleep with one eye open.
Flipping your pillow tight.
Okay, ich lass euch meine...
Ich spar euch meine Sing-Skills.
Hehehe.
Twitch sings.
Ja, Gott, ey, das...
Bäh.
Aber ich kann, ich kann die meisten Texte.
Also die meisten ollen Metallica-Texte zum größten Teil auch auswendig.
Shuffle light.
Äh.
Okay.
Doch nicht.
Dreams of war.
Dreams of fire.
Dreams of dragon.
Fire.
Äh.
Okay, ich kann's auch nicht mehr komplett auswendig.
Hehehe.
Jutsch.
Hey, das ist ewig her.
Wir müssen unbedingt einbauen, dass man verschiedene Größen haben kann.
Wir müssen ein bisschen Metallica-Musik mal anmachen.
Sag mal, das piepst, oder?
Die Musik, das piepst?
Jetzt hört man's nicht mehr.
Doch, das piepst.
Was ist das für ne Kackaufnahme?
Viel zu hell.
Alter, sind die alt geworden, ey.
Und das ist von 2009.
Da waren die...
Die sind ja noch älter mittlerweile.
Super, Kobi.
Da kann ich mich leider nicht dran erinnern.
Aber Velfi3-Gameplays kann man immer brauchen.
Wenn ich mal Videos machen würde.
Okay, wir proggern's.
Wir proggern's jetzt.
Also.
Eigentlich bin ich total bescheuert.
Ich hab doch Amazon...
Ich hab doch Amazon, ähm...
...Music.
Da könnten wir das eigentlich direkt anmachen.
Ah, da...
Da...
Ich mein...
Die...
Der Wort...
Wort ist eh schon RIP jetzt.
Wort ist eh RIP.
Es gibt viel zu wenig Leute, die Heavy Metal mögen heutzutage.
Find ich.
Ich mein, es gibt immer noch viele.
Es ist ja...
Grad ist ja Wacken.
Hier.
Dieses Wochenende.
Wenn ich...
Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Dann wird's wieder voll sein.
Aber...
Es gibt mit Sicherheit in Deutschland deutlich mehr, die Haftbefehl hören, als Leute, die Metallica hören.
Haft.
Yami.
Goethe Straße.
Louis Vuitton Store.
Das ist einzigartig.
Was ich kann.
Das ist das einzige, was ich je von Haftbefehl gemerkt hab.
Goethe Straße.
Louis Vuitton Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Mehr kann ich nicht.
Muss man auch nicht können.
Ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass das...
...hervorzuheben wäre, wenn man krasse Haftbefehl-Lyrics kann.
Forsen.
Ja, das ist nice.
Wenn du das beruhigend findest.
Ich mein, vielleicht außer die Videos, wo ich mich ein bisschen über irgendwas aufrege.
Ich bin immer noch der Ansicht, da werde ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich den Herz aller Metallica-Fans zuziehen,
ähm, ich hab das ja früher auch saumäßig oft gehört,
und so im Nachhinein, und ich hab's dann, ich hab's dann jahrelang auch nicht mehr gehört,
aber wie gesagt, die meisten, äh, die meisten Texte krieg ich immer noch halbwegs zusammen.
Aber ich finde, was Metallica echt gut getan hätte, wäre ein ordentlicher Sänger.
Weil die Musik ist übelst nice, aber ich kann mit dem Gesang heute überhaupt nichts mehr anfangen.
Vor allem, vor allem, weil, weil...
...der muss bei allen Aufnahmen, ähm...
...während er singt, macht er immer yeah, oder irgendwie sowas.
Das geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Was hab ich Plutone an?
So, in was fangen wir an?
Ich würd sagen, wir gucken jetzt erst mal, wie man Chrome fernsteuern kann,
bevor wir das mit der Website ausprobieren.
Hallo, Tante Micha.
Hafti ist schon längst out.
Jetzt ist Capital Bra der neueste Scheiß.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ich hab nur letztens einen Artikel gelesen...
Hau mal hier aus.
Ich hab nur letztens einen Artikel irgendwo gelesen,
dass Kollegah jetzt seine ultrakrassen Fanboys mit einem...
...oh, wie, wie, wie nennt er es? Mit, mit...
...Boss, nee, Alpha...
...Alpha Mentoring, oder so.
Ähm...
...Skamast.
Nee, nee, nicht Boss-Transformation.
Boss-Transformation ist ja out.
Du kannst jetzt, du kannst jetzt bei Kollegah...
...irgendwie so nen...
...so nen Mäntel, so nen, so nen, so nen...
...wie werd ich auch krasser Alpha-Kurs, ähm...
...buchen...
...für irgendwie läppische 2K...
...oder 2000 im Monat irgendwie...
...ist übelst da hängengeblieben auf jeden Fall, äh...
...also egal ob 2000 oder 2000 im Monat, das macht's ja dann auch schon gar nicht mehr auf.
Ähm...
...macht's ja auch schon gar nicht mehr aus, aber...
...also...
...wie man auf die Idee kommt...
...das kann doch...
...das kann doch eigentlich nur jemand auf die Idee kommen, da mitzumachen, der einfach...
...sagen wir mal...
...hardcore Kollegah-Fan ist...
...und, ähm...
...so'n bisschen...
...so'n bisschen die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren hat, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt im wörtlichen Sinn, ja...
...hat er wegen Backlash aber auch schon wieder abgesagt.
Naja, also der Artikel ist von vor nem Tag gewesen und bis dahin ist das auch noch gelaufen.
Kennste keine Aufschieberittes?
Doch, doch, klar, das hat...
...ja, das ist jeder, ja...
...ich...
...zumindest mal, wenn ich irgendwas machen muss, guck ich erst mal zwei Stunden YouTube-Videos, bevor ich was mach.
Ist immer so.
Also immer, wenn's was ist, was ich nicht gerne mach.
Und du musstest wohl, dass du in diesem...
...also zumindest war das...
...stand das in diesem Artikel so drinne...
...dass du quasi bei diesem...
...geilen Alpha-Mentoring-Programm mitmachen darfst...
...musstest du erst mal so ne, so ne...
...musstest du erst mal nen...
...nen Fragebogen ausfüllen...
...und in dem Fragebogen wurde natürlich...
...rein zufällig auch abgefragt, wie so deine finanziellen Verhältnisse sind.
Und, ähm...
...wahrscheinlich haben sie gleich die Leute aussortiert, die gesagt haben, sie haben kein Geld.
Übrigens, letztens war auf Twitter nen Trend...
...vor was man Angst hat...
...und ich hab geschrieben...
...ähm...
...mein, es gibt noch mehr, aber...
...man konnte, glaub ich, maximal drei Sachen schreiben...
...ich hab geschrieben, Kinder, Java und Overwatch ranked...
...und sie im Nachhinein hätt ich noch mehr schreiben können, aber das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich wollt nicht...
...ich mein, ich hätte auch...
...komplett...
...Menschen hinschreiben können, ja...
...aber Kinder gehen mir besonders oft Kicks.
Vor allem im Zug.
So, okay.
Also...
...Puppetier brauchen wir zum Chrome-Fernsteuern.
Schau mal, wie das geht. Das ist übrigens auch ne schöne Sache...
...ähm...
...ich hab jetzt für die Arbeit...ich hab, ich hab, ähm...
...mit dem Original...
...Node.js-Ding...
...hab ich für die Arbeit mal was gebastelt, und zwar...
...ähm...
...mit dem Original Chrome-Fernsteuer-Ding...
...und zwar ist das so...
...dass unser Support...
...ähm...
...muss mehrfach am Tag...
...Spam-E-Mails...
...ähm...
...accepten, also Spam-E-Mails aus dem...
...aus dem Spam-Ordner...
...quasi freigeben...
...und...
...das ist, das ist ganz schön...
...ätzend im Endeffekt, ja...
...und...
...hab ich halt das, äh...
...hab ich Chrome genommen, dieses...
...Papetier für Node.js...
...und hab einfach die paar Klicks...
...die man im Webinterface macht, nachgebaut...
...in, in Node.js...
...und seitdem funktioniert das wunderbar...
...da werden jetzt automatisch...
...einmal in der Stunde alle Spam-Mails...
...freigegeben...
...also prinzipiell hab ich das...prinzipiell weiß ich, wie man das verwendet...
...so halbwegs...
...und, äh, es funktioniert echt gut...
...so...
...also installieren wir den Kram erst einmal...
...und wie ist es mir jetzt, nachdem...
...nachdem wir da Metallica gehört haben, kann ich mir jetzt gerade irgendwie kein...
...kein, äh, chill...
...chillgesteppe geben, äh...
...machen wir jetzt mal...
...warte, das ganze Album ist auf...
...ist das ganze Album auf...
...YouTube...
...mitlerweile haben sie...
...das ist sicherlich nur eine private...
...Sicherheitskopie, die er halt irgendwo off-site...
...speichern musste...
...jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen...
...zackigere Sachen hören...
...Gloryhammer, übelst nice...
...Album rausgebracht, aber das, das, das da...
...find ich immer noch besser, das Beste von ihm bisher...
...muss ein bisschen leiser machen, ne?
...oder?
...geht das so?
...okay, Puppetier, wo ist hier?
...Puppetier, Sharp...
...äh, was ist denn?
...hier, da...
...oder?
...das Richtige...
...kannst du mal einen VHS-Code-Einführungsstream machen?
...ja...
...allerdings gibt's eigentlich nicht viel...
...in Original Studio Code...
...kannst du mal einen VHS-Code einführen...
...äh...
...so viel gibt's da eigentlich gar nicht...
...so, Accept...
...wofür braucht man...
...CMDR?
...brauchen tust du das gar nicht...
...also, es ist ganz nützlich...
...für, wenn man ein ordentliches Terminal braucht...
...weil ich mein...
...das da...
...ist halt kein ordentliches Terminal...
...das ist eher Woodface...
...das war auch sowas...
...das ist eigentlich nur auf Twitch...
...das würde beispielsweise...
...auf Mixer nicht funktionieren...
...weil da gibt's die E-Mails nicht...
...Mixer ist jetzt halt...
...seit Ninja dahin gewechselt ist...
...die zweitmeist downgeloadete...
...Entertainment-App im letzten...
...in diesem Jahr oder so...
...alja...
...okay, die meisten Leute sind wirklich keine Heavy-Metal-Fans...
...eben hatte ich irgendwie 105 Viewer...
...und jetzt hab ich 80...
...einfach mal alle raus, alle weg, alle abgeschaltet...
...ja...
...was...
...was kann CMD mehr...
...und was ist anders...
...du kannst ordentlich Copy-Pasten...
...du hast ein paar...
...Linux-Kommandozeilen-Befehle...
...du kannst das Fenster ordentlich resizen...
...du kannst das Fenster...
...per Shortcuts bedienen...
...du kannst ein ordentliches Farbschema geben...
...was mit CMD nicht geht...
...du kannst verschiedene Shells einstellen...
...du kannst Tabs haben, also du kannst im Prinzip alles machen...
...was man mit ordentlichen Terminal machen kann...
...was man mit CMD nicht machen kann...
...wobei man sagen muss...
...CMD, das ist so ein bisschen...
...in Windows ist ein bisschen schwammig das Ganze...
...also...
...das da, was da läuft...
...ist eigentlich...
...also normalerweise muss man das unterscheiden...
...es gibt das Terminal-Programm...
...das ist das Fenster im Endeffekt...
...was den Text darstellt...
...und es gibt eine Shell, die da drin läuft...
...bei Windows ist das alles CMD in einem...
...was für Shell gibt es denn dann vorhin...
...WSL, wenn man WSL installiert hat...
...aber ich habe...
...WSL nicht installiert...
...Bash...
...darin sage ich sogar nicht...
...die Bash-Git-Shell, wenn es installiert ist...
...ZSH...
...ja gut, ZSH kannst du unter...
...WSL kannst du natürlich installieren...
...das neue Windows-Terminal...
...geht in die richtige Richtung...
...aber es ist noch zu langsam...
...ok, also wir haben jetzt den Kreml installiert...
...da können wir jetzt mal...
...versuchen...
...den Chrome fernzusteuern...
...
Warte, da haben die ordentliche Examples, Demos hier.
Sharp PDF Demo.
Launch Option, Headless True.
Der Browser Fetcher.
Ach ja klar, der muss natürlich erstmal die Chrome Binaries runterladen, das ist logisch.
Kubuntu, genau.
Hast du das neue Terminal schon angeschaut? Ja, haben wir gemacht.
Ach, das haben wir schon vor einem Monat oder so gemacht, als es ganz neu war.
Ich habe extra damals eine Windows vor allem installiert.
Mit der neuesten Windows Version, nur um das Terminal ausprobieren zu können.
Was willst du eigentlich mit Puppeteer zaubern?
Ich will Pakete verfolgen, als Backup zur offiziellen API von den Anbietern.
Und vielleicht für Hermos, weil Hermos keine offizielle API hat.
Und weil ich generell gucken will, wie man es mit .NET verwendet.
Okay, New Browser Fetcher.
Ich muss jetzt gleich mal angucken, wie der Kram funktioniert.
New Browser Fetcher. Das machen wir mal.
Also.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, downloadet mir das jetzt den neuesten Chrome.
Ach ja.
Man kann jetzt übrigens, das ist neu.
Das ist neu in, ich glaube, seit C Sharp 7 ist das neu, dass man in Main.
Oder 7.3?
Ich glaube, seit 7.
Ist das neu, dass man Main Async machen kann?
Das ging früher nicht.
Früher muss, ich meine, du kannst, früher war es auch nicht viel schwieriger.
Du hast halt hier irgendwie eine neue Klasse gemacht, mit Methoden drin hast du ausgeführt.
Und dann gesagt, einfach wait.
Das hat natürlich auch funktioniert.
Aber so ist es schöner.
Okay, jetzt downloadet er Chrome.
Und wie geht es weiter?
Async Launch Options.
Puppeteer Browser.
Browser await Launch Options Async.
Ja, machen wir.
Geht es?
Browser.
Wir machen, wir machen erstmal nicht Headless.
Wir machen nicht Headless.
Ich will, ich will den Chrome ja, ich will den Chrome ja sehen.
Options lassen wir weg.
So, jetzt startet er in Chrome.
Ach, muss man Options angeben?
Okay, wenn man Options angeben muss, dann geben wir halt Options an und sagen Headless ist false.
So, aha.
Immer noch keine Subs, Emotes.
Ja, ich war die ganze Woche am arbeiten.
Stell dir das vor!
Und ich bin...
sehr unkreativ, was sowas
angeht. Und
ich hab noch keine Idee so richtig.
Und dazu kommt, dass im Discord-Channel
leider auch keine ordentlichen
Vorschläge drin sind für Emotes,
die man machen könnte.
Ah, jetzt schnurren wir die Musik mal.
Leise, hä?
Okay, wir gucken mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert,
ob der jetzt in Chrome startet.
Der sollte jetzt in Chrome starten.
Und bei New Page
müssen wir vielleicht noch machen. New Page, go Google.
Genau.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Der sollte jetzt
sich jetzt in Chrome
irgendwie eine minimal, oder halt
irgendeine ausführbare
Chrome-Version für meine
Plattform runterladen.
Casino-Kapitalist, ja,
dann ist Monkatos angesagt.
Wenn ich da Emotes draus nehme.
Der sollte jetzt in Chrome runterladen.
Der sollte
einen Tab aufmachen
und eine neue Seite
laden, auf Google gehen und
dann nichts machen. Gucken wir mal, ob das
funktioniert.
Downloading Chrome.
Dann downloaden wir Chrome.
Das muss er nur einmal machen.
Das muss er nur das erste Mal machen.
Danach ist das zwischengespeichert.
Bam, da ist er.
Chrome is being
controlled by automated test software.
Da ist er.
Ein frischer,
ferngesteuerter Chrome.
So.
PDFs wollen wir nicht generieren.
Also, dann
probieren wir das Ganze doch mal
aus.
Dann probieren wir das Ganze doch mal aus.
Wir probieren das mal mit einer DHL.
Wir machen das
Hermes-Tracking. Wir machen das
Hermes-Tracking von eben.
Das da hinten ist, würde ich sagen,
der Anbieter, der das Paket transportiert.
Und das hier vorne ist die
Paketnummer.
Die Tracking-Nummer.
Warum wird Chrome eigentlich so einfach benutzt?
Äh, so oft benutzt?
Naja, in dem Fall wird Chrome benutzt, weil
er einfach fernzusteuern ist.
Und ich
weiß gar nicht,
ob Firefox was ähnliches hat.
Okay, ähm.
Also, gehen wir mal auf die Seite.
Dann sollte, dann sollte irgendwelches
Zeug geladen werden.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Der sollte jetzt eigentlich die gleiche Seite
wieder aufmachen.
Ach so, haha.
Moment, wir müssen, wir müssen, glaube ich,
warten.
Der macht die Seite, glaube ich, wieder zu.
Wir müssen warten.
Go to page async.
Ich glaube, wir müssen warten.
Wir müssen, wir müssen
hier theoretisch warten, dass der
als wir zugucken können.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht die schönste Art
und Weise, da zu warten, aber
wir müssen, wir müssen erstmal zwei Sekunden warten,
dass wir sehen, dass der das macht.
Ja, funktioniert.
Ähm, das ist gut.
Nice.
Was hältst du von Brave Org?
Ist dein Chromium-Bild?
Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also, machen wir hier sowas wie hier
Tracking.
Tracking, ist das da?
Dann haben wir noch, äh, äh, äh,
die Carrier oder so, nennen wir das mal.
Das ist das da.
Also, das ist in dem Fall Hermes.
Ähm,
String Interpolation.
Äh, äh,
wann hab ich das falsch rum gemacht?
Kann man sich mal nicht merken.
Man sollte es vielleicht auch an die
richtige Stelle schreiben, dann funktioniert das auch.
Omega-Lol.
Easy.
Ähm, ja, das sind so
Kleingramen, den übersieht man immer.
Und den übersehen irgendwie alle,
also ich kenn keinen, der nicht ab und zu mal so
Kram übersieht, deswegen finde ich die
Diskussion, die es immer gibt, darüber,
welche, also,
wie man noch optimierter
Text eingibt beim Programmieren,
ist dann vollkommen überflüssig, weil die meiste
Zeit,
hast du dir eh Gedanken.
Was checkst mal out?
Was soll ich auschecken?
Ja, Yannick,
Genius.
Wo steht das?
Ach hier, Brave Org.
Ja, muss ich mir mal angucken.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
So, ähm,
mal gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Jetzt muss die Tracking-App wieder aufgehen.
Ah, gut, passt.
Okay, und nu, jetzt wird's
bisschen komplizierter. Jetzt müssen wir erst mal
auf der Seite
checken, wie das Ganze überhaupt funktioniert.
Weil,
es ist jetzt ja so, ich muss jetzt irgendwie aus der Seite
rausholen, was für nen,
was für nen Status die,
die, die Sendung hat.
Keiner funktioniert so gut wie Chrome.
Ich bin mit Chrome auch wirklich zufrieden.
Ich kann mich da über Chrome, ehrlich gesagt,
gar nicht großartig beschweren.
So, jetzt sind mal unsere krassen
Reverse-Engineering-Künste
gefragt, dass wir rauskriegen,
wie die, wie die Seite funktioniert.
Äh!
Öh!
Was übertragen die denn da alles?
3000 JavaScript
und CSS und
Gedöns-Zeugs, ja.
Okay, Moment, wir müssen das mal groß machen.
Und wir müssen
die Dev-Tools mal irgendwie rechts hin machen,
dass man auch ein bisschen was sieht.
Okay, noch mal gucken, dass jetzt nix im Cache ist.
Aus dem Cache-Laden, okay.
Ähm, so.
Also.
Wir brauchen
Track.
Da haben wir doch,
das sieht doch schon mal interessant aus.
JavaScript juckt uns nichts.
Uns jucken Requests zum Server.
Das ist das hier.
Ha! Nice.
Ähm.
Was genau übertragen
die da?
Das ist kryptische, äh,
kryptisches China-Zeug,
was die da übertragen.
Track. B704
C0. Was zum Teufel machen die da?
0.
Red 1. Message
okay, okay. Also.
Sex.
Pff. Ah, okay. Das hier
sind die...
Sendung wurde zugestellt.
Das hier sind die Einzelheiten
von...
Also, der Progress.
Das ist richtig
pepega-api. Das ist aber auch keine offizielle
von denen, ne? Also, ich mein,
es ist hier zwar unter REST-API Track,
aber ich wette mit euch, das funktioniert
nur, wenn man irgendwelche passenden Cookies
gesetzt hat und... Also, ich geh mal
davon aus, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach
hergehen.
Copy.
Copy as Curl. Bash.
Nice. Das funktioniert.
Ich denke mal, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach
nen Curl machen.
Aha!
Okay, vielleicht brauchen wir den Kram mit Chrome gar nicht.
Naja, doch. Ja, ich guck mal,
ich übersetz... Ich hab hier diese ganzen
Cookies gesetzt.
Da hab ich keinen Bock, das von Hand zu bauen.
Creeps HD.
Nice. Dankeschön.
Stufe 1 Sub. Heute gibt's wenig
Prime-Subs.
Subscriber!
Ein
nicer Sub.
Dankeschön. Creeps HD.
Wie lange streamst du heute? Kein Schimmer.
So, mal gucken, ob der Mist auch
ohne Cookies und
haste nicht
gesehen funktioniert.
Ich glaube eher
nicht.
Ne, guckt.
Achso.
Ich hab den Header weggemacht.
Ne, guckt. Das geht nicht.
Das funktioniert nur, wenn man die passenden
Cookies und irgendwelche
Y
Q Bit
gesetzt haben und was auch immer.
Irgendein China Cookie
V5 Translator.
Blade Express.
Last Event
ID. Keine Ahnung.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Deswegen hab ich mir
schon in, nennen wir's mal
weiser Voraussicht
überlegt, dass wir das besser
mit nem Remote gesteuerten Chrome machen.
Weil, wenn wir das mit nem Remote
gesteuerten Chrome machen,
dann
müssen wir diesen ganzen Kram wie Cookies und so
nicht von Hand machen. Das macht Chrome
für uns. Aber
es ist natürlich trotzdem wichtig,
dass wir den
Aufruf mitkriegen, weil in dem Aufruf
hier, da, steht ja letztendlich
drinne, in JSON,
irgendwie
in nem komischen Format, aber
es steht letztendlich
lesbar drinne,
wo sich die Sendung gerade
befindet. Das heißt,
es ist allemal besser,
das aus diesem JSON-Request raus
zu fuddeln, der gemacht wird,
als aus dem HTML,
was generiert wird, rauszuparsen.
Also das HTML-Parsen ist wirklich
das allerletzte,
was ich machen würde,
wenn ich an so Informationen
reinkommen will, weil
das Problem ist, wenn du anfängst, irgendwelche HTML-Sachen
zu parsen, das ist, das
geht morgen schon kaputt. Das ist
einfach nicht stabil, HTML-Geparse.
200 IQ, ja.
Deswegen
müssen wir gucken, dass wir irgendwie an diesen
JSON-Request, also an dieses
JSON-Response rankommen,
der gemacht wird, wenn man die Seite aufruft.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt irgendwie mal
schauen, wie man sich
in die Chrome
Fernsteuerung
mit Puppeteer
reinhängen kann, dass man mitbekommt,
wenn ein
JSON-Request,
also wenn
ein Post-Request
gemacht wird, dass ich
mich da reinhucken kann irgendwie.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Mal schauen,
ob die vielleicht ordentliche...
Hier, schau mal, Puppe-Tier-Doc.
Das ist ja keine
.NET-spezifische Sache.
Ja, das sieht schon
besser aus. So, nach was müssen wir da
mal suchen? Dankeschön, Nobody-Q.
Feels birthday, man.
Boah, nach
was könnten wir denn mal da suchen?
Wie, Hook?
Nee.
Request?
Ich will ja letztendlich
einen Post-Request mitkriegen.
Event-Request.
Request finished.
Class Page.
Request finished. Das klingt schon
mal Request und Request finished.
Das klingt schon mal ganz praktisch.
Wait for Request.
Class Request.
Set Request Interception.
Das klingt auch gut.
Event-Request finished.
Emitted when a Request
finished successfully.
Poggers Englisch wieder.
Easy.
Willst du nicht eher die Response...
Na, ich hoffe mal, dass man
die Response lesen kann, wenn man
Request macht.
Also, wenn dann Request
fertig, dann Response
davon anzeigen.
Aber du hast prinzipiell recht.
Ich will schon den Response haben.
Können wir mal gucken. Vielleicht gibt es sowas wie
Response finished oder so.
Emitted
when a Response is received. Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich
dann noch besser.
Das ist tatsächlich dann noch besser.
Set Request
Interception. Nee, das stimmt.
Du hast recht.
Das ist viel sinnvoller, wenn man nach Response geht.
Intercept.
Vielleicht gibt es auch Intercept Response.
Okay, was machen die hier?
Set Page Request Interception
true. Page on Request
Intercept Request.
Nee, das wollen wir eher nicht.
Response.
Ich habe irgendwas von einem Event mit Response gesehen.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus. Also.
Page. Response.
Hängen wir uns mal
an das Event ran.
Wir machen das dann inline
mit irgendeinem Lambda, aber
erstmal hier gucken,
ob wir da irgendwas rauskriegen
bei der ganzen Sache.
So, Response created.
Was kriegen wir denn da?
Response. Da ist es doch.
From Cache, Frame,
Headers.
Mein Visual Studio laggt.
Huge Visual Studio lag.
Warte mal kurz, ich muss das neu starten.
Weiß nicht, was damit los ist, aber es laggt wie Sau gerade.
Läuft irgendein Mist im Hintergrund
oder so?
Krassen. Hexos am Start.
So.
Läuft nix im Hintergrund.
Na gut, machen wir weiter.
Ähm.
Ja, außer, außer
vmware läuft nix.
Warum braucht
vmware überhaupt
überhaupt so viel CPU Last?
Oh, ihr seht nix, ne?
Ups.
Ups, ups, ups.
Jetzt.
Ja, das ist ein Bug.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Bug in OBS.
Das, wenn man diesen
Windows Passwort prompt kriegt, das
man
das ist abkackt.
Die Bildschirmaufnahme. Warum auch immer.
Konsole App.
Zwölf waren wir.
Was ist denn los? Freitag Abend, nur 80 Zuschauer?
Das bin ich ja gar nicht mehr gewöhnt, ey.
Alle hier
am Party Parrot machen.
From cache headers.
Headers.
Alte Header, Digga.
Digga Header.
Ähm.
Wo ist
Wo ist Body oder sowas?
Gibt's da Text? Hier, Text.
Text.
Text representation of body.
Das wollen wir haben.
Text.
Okay.
Also, ich sollte jetzt für jeden Request, den
mein ferngesteuerter Crow macht,
ähm.
Ne Ausgabe in dem Terminal
kriegen, wo drinsteht, was er für
äh, die Response. Also quasi jegliche
Response.
Von dem, was bei dem Seitenaufbau
quasi
reinkommt in den Browser,
sollte ich jetzt in, in, in
der Kommandozeile kriegen.
Okay, das ist natürlich ein bisschen was.
Ähm.
Und unformatiert
ist das natürlich ziemlicher Müll.
Wir kriegen jetzt hier alles im Endeffekt.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt mal irgendwie
filtern.
Das filtern wir jetzt mal.
Das kannst du ja komplett vergessen.
Wieso machst du alles Essing, um es dann wieder
zu Awaiten? Naja, weil ich, weil ich
was ausgeben will.
Wenn ich was ausgeben will, muss ich
Awaiten, bis die Ausgabe da ist.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich das so mache?
Ja genau, dann krieg ich einfach
nur die Klasse zurück. Das bringt nichts.
Ne, ich muss da schon Awaiten.
Allerdings ist Await in dem Fall
kein Sleep. Das ist auch so
ne Sache. Ich hab das, ich hab ne, ich hab ne Weile
gebraucht, bis ich das kapiert hab.
Ähm.
Das ist im Prinzip nen Return
aus der Funktion und
ähm
erst wenn es fertig
ist, geht's
weiter an der Stelle.
Also unter der Haube macht er quasi
hier nen Return aus der Funktion
und das blockt nicht.
Der, der geht einfach aus, der, der
hier steht eigentlich nen Return da, davor noch.
So quasi.
Return.
Und dann ruft er die Funktion wieder auf
und dann springt er halt nicht da oben hin, wo
Return drin steht, sondern hier unten, wo dann
die Response drin ist.
Es gibt ein richtig cooles Video zum Thema
Async Await, hab ich gesehen.
Ähm, von einem der letzten
Build-Konferenzen war das, glaube ich.
Wie hieß das denn?
Irgendwie sowas wie Async Await Mistakes
oder so? In der Richtung?
Weiß gar nicht.
War das überhaupt Build?
Das war ein ziemlich gutes Video, wo jemand
erklärt hat, wie Async Await intern funktioniert.
Ja, genau das da.
Das da.
Das ist ein ziemlich gutes Video, der erklärt,
wie das intern funktioniert.
Wie Async Await, wie das
quasi implementiert ist.
Und warum es eben nicht blockt
oder trotzdem blockt, wenn man es
verkehrt benutzt.
Ja, warum nicht?
Bisschen mehr Action
könnte in der Musik jetzt auch drin sein.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt in dem Response
auf jeden Fall mal nach was Sinnvollem
suchen. Ähm.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Ha! Ich habe eine Idee.
Huge. Big Brain.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Wir wissen noch, welche Uhr das Ganze ist.
Ähm. Response.
Und zwar
können wir gucken,
if response
und da ist garantiert
irgendwie die Uhr drin,
die der...
Ich will nicht Text Async, ich will einfach nur Response.
Response. Und da ist garantiert
irgendwo die Uhr drin.
Ist ja gut.
Okay, dann brauche ich auch nicht Await.
Ähm.
Da ist garantiert irgendwo die Uhr drin.
Remote Address.
Uhr. Genau.
So, und wenn die Uhr
das hier ist, weil das haben wir doch rausgekriegt
eben gerade.
Die Uhr. Wo haben wir es?
Irgendwo. Ich habe sie doch kopiert.
Wenn das da
die Uhr ist,
die aufgerufen wird,
nur dann wollen wir es ausgeben.
Ich brauche jetzt schon mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Await.
Response.
So. Async Text.
So, und jetzt sollten wir nur von dem
hoffentlich richtigen Request
die Ausgabe kriegen.
Ja.
Bam. Funktioniert. Pock.
Easy. Richtig easy.
Und habt ihr euch auch schon einen Mixer Account
gemacht, Leute? Nope.
Ich auch nicht.
Erinnert ihr euch noch an den
ich mache mir auch keinen Mixer Account.
Wozu? Ninja gucke ich
eh nicht. Und
ja, Rest juckt mich
auch nicht so wirklich. Könnt ihr euch noch an den
E3 Stream
von vor ein paar Jahren erinnern?
Wo die Age of Empires
Typen auf Mixer gestreamt haben
und ihre Streamproben
aus versehenes Mikrofon eingeschaltet haben.
Twitch Tracker. Okay.
Was auch immer.
Genau.
Das ist der Clip hier.
Das haben wir gesehen.
Da waren wir im Stream
und wollten einfach nur gucken,
wann geht der Age of Empires Stream los.
Ah, von der Gamescom. Und auf einmal haben sie ihre
Trockenübungen gestreamt.
Ich glaube, die haben aus
versehen den Stream eingeschaltet und wollten gar nicht.
Jetzt ist er wieder aus.
Ja, da hat man im Hintergrund
die Trockenübungen gehört, wo sie geübt haben
zu jubeln und sowas bei Ankündigungen.
Richtig Fail.
Ninja streamt nicht mehr bei Twitch.
Anscheinend nicht.
Es gehen irgendwie
die Gerüchte um, dass er
930 Millionen
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall verdammt viel Geld
dafür bekommen hat.
Exklusiv 6 Jahre für
Mixer.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wer das ist,
ob das vertrauenswürdig ist.
Das ist nicht legit.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich habe das schon mal auf Twitter gelesen,
aber ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen.
930 Millionen wäre extrem krass viel.
Für einen Streamer.
Ich meine, das ist der größte Streamer.
Dass es in Millionen,
dass es in Millionenhöhe liegt,
ist klar,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass es ernsthaft,
das glaube ich nicht.
Humor, Humor.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Aber es wird mit Sicherheit in Millionenhöhe liegen.
Garantiert.
Der wird so krass
die Kohle kriegen dafür.
Das lohnt sich für ihn.
Und
ich bin mir noch
unschlüssig, ob das
was das für Auswirkungen
haben wird.
Ich habe mir da gestern ein bisschen Gedanken zu gemacht und
es gibt ja im Prinzip
zwei Sachen, wie das Ganze ausgehen kann.
Entweder
wird Mixer jetzt Konkurrent für Twitch.
Das glaube ich allerdings.
Das kann ich nicht glauben.
Das wird auch Ninja alleine nicht schaffen.
Er wird
ein paar Fans mitbringen, aber ob
deswegen Mixer auf einmal
ein ernsthafter Twitch Konkurrent wird,
ich kann es mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Mir gefällt auch Mixer von der Seite her nicht.
Der nächste Fall, der ist,
ist genau umgedreht.
Mixer bleibt
verhältnismäßig unbedeutend.
Und Ninja verliert
extrem an Einfluss und Bedeutung.
Das ist eigentlich die Sache.
Wozu ich eher tendiere.
Allerdings ist Ninja mittlerweile so groß.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der überhaupt
noch richtig abhängig ist von irgendeiner
Plattform.
Wahrscheinlich könnte der auf
Chatroubaid
oder so streamen.
Oder er hätte 14.000 Viewer oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist wahrscheinlich bei Ninja mittlerweile egal,
wo er streamt.
Der Sibaro droppt hier wieder die Seiten.
Easy.
Okay, machen wir weiter. Also, wenn Response
REST API track,
dann wollen wir die Response
als Text.
Klingt irgendwie sinnvoll, oder?
Was wir da gebastelt haben.
Ist der Packet Tracker für was spezifisches?
Ja, der ist für OPS, DHL,
Hermes, DPD
und, wenn wir es hinkriegen, für Amazon.
Aktuell probieren wir gerade
den Hermes-Stand über
hier diese Tracking-Seite
abzufragen, weil Hermes
keine API bietet. DHL hat
eine API, DPD hat eine API,
Hermes hat keine API.
Was, wie sieht es mit
China-Post aus? Das sollte nicht
so schwer sein. Können wir auch einbauen,
aber erstmal will ich die Sachen einbauen,
wo ich selbst relativ viele Pakete
mitkriege.
Danach, wenn man das ordentlich
baut, kann man eh weitere Anbieter
relativ easy integrieren.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir den Kram noch irgendwie
parsern, würde ich sagen.
So, jetzt haben wir den Text.
Ja.
Den, den, den.
Aber hier den Body als
als String.
Das müssen wir jetzt, das müssen wir jetzt parsen.
Wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen jetzt das JSON-Objekt
uns erstmal schnappen.
JSON-Convert.
Da machen wir uns vielleicht
wirklich eine eigene Klasse für,
die wir dann direkt deserialisen
können. Oh, Twitch Prime!
Huge! Neradon!
Ne, nicht, nicht, nicht mal Prime.
Richtig, richtig, äh,
richtiger Sub. Also kein, kein
sondern ein,
ein, ein richtiger
Dankeschön
für Stufe 1.
Neradon POC.
Ey, Max, warum lern ich mir absolut keine Ahnung,
was das ist? Ähm, ich bastel
ne Software,
oder ich probiere, was, ähm,
was zu programmieren,
was Pakete trackt.
Allerdings nicht einfach nur Pakete trackt, sondern
dein E-Mail-Postfach durchsucht
nach gültigen Tracking-Nummern.
Und, ähm,
dann quasi die selbstständig
trackt und dir Bescheid sagt, wann deine Pakete
kommen. Das heißt, in Zukunft
musst du eigentlich nur gucken, dass
du die gleiche E-Mail-Adresse verwendest
bei allen Online-Shops.
Und so ziemlich jeder Online-Shop, den's
gibt, verschickt ne, ne Mail, wenn das
Ganze verschickt ist. Ich mein, sogar AliExpress
macht das. Und in diesen E-Mails steht
in der Regel ja auch immer drinne, ähm,
sehr geehrter Herr XY,
ähm, ihre, ihre
Sendung wurde verschickt
mit DHL
und das ist die Tracking-Nummer.
Da steht ja dann in der Regel immer drin.
Ich kenn eigentlich keinen Shop, wo das nicht drinsteht.
Das heißt, wir machen das in drei Teilen.
Ähm, wir scannen einmal
die E-Mails nach Tracking-Nummern
plus ein paar weitere Sachen, ja.
Also, wir haben's uns hier letztens aufgeschrieben, wie wir das,
wie wir das Ganze machen müssen. Ich kann's ja nochmal kurz zeigen.
Äh,
haben wir das nicht gespeichert? Kann das sein?
Da ich so dämlich war
und das nicht zu speichern vom letzten Mal.
Das ist, äh,
ziemlich pepega.
Naja, zumindest
dann erklär ich das jetzt nochmal.
Wir bauen drei Teile. Wir bauen einmal einen Teil, der
deine E-Mails scannt und, äh, quasi
versucht den Anbieter rauszukriegen
und die Tracking-Nummer rauszukriegen.
In Kombination eben noch mit vielleicht deinem Namen,
dass nicht so viele E-Mails durchrutschen,
die nicht, äh, gar keine
Versandnachrichten sind. Danach wird
das Ganze getrackt.
Es gibt ein ordentliches, es gibt ein halbwegs, äh,
hübsches,
sofern das meine CSS-Skills
äh, hergeben. Ähm,
ein Webinterface, wo der Status angezeigt wird
und, ähm,
auch eine MQTT-Benachrichtigung für deine
HM-Automatisierung, falls du eine hast
und halt eine Notification
an. Mal gucken, was wir da unterstützen,
wenn ein Paket ankommt. Und das Schöne daran
ist ja, ich mein, es gibt wie Sand am Meer Programme,
die deine Pakete
tracken, allerdings
nicht
automatisch. Du musst immer noch die Nummer einfügen.
Ja.
Und das, äh, stell ich mir eigentlich
ganz nice vor.
Magst schon mal von Pokémon Mini
gehört? Nein.
Parcel Track kann das.
Ich weiß, dass die das können.
Allerdings will ich meine E-Mails nicht an andere, an
externen Anbieter weiterleiten.
Wahrscheinlich wird meine App oder mein Programm
am Ende auch nie wirklich
so gut funktionieren, wie das Parcel Track macht,
weil ich mein, die unterstützen was? 85 Anbieter
oder so?
Also es wird nicht wirklich Konkurrenz dazu sein.
Aber für
Leute, die sich das nicht
kaufen wollen, oder die ihre
E-Mails nicht an externen Anbieter weiterleiten wollen,
oder denen es reicht, wenn sie mit den
Sachen in Deutschland zurechtkommen,
also DHL, UPS,
DPD, Hermes, Amazon,
dann können die, dass die dann auch
damit zufrieden sind, denke ich mal.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir den Mist erstmal
hier, okay, wir haben's importiert.
Ähm,
jetzt müssen wir das Ding erstmal als
Parcel
was wir da haben.
Parcel,
nämlich den
Körper, der Körper
wird geparst.
Und
da kriegen wir dann ein
JSON-Objekt raus und das können
wir mal ausgeben
und schauen, ob wir das
richtige geparst haben.
Haben wir! Okay, also wir haben
schon mal die, die China
Response, haben wir schon mal mit
ganz merkwürdigen Sachen drin, was könnte
denn da was sein? Ich bin da jetzt grad ein bisschen
unschlüssig.
Z0 haben wir?
Die Dinger sind ja auch absolut grausam benannt, ne?
Reicht es nicht,
sich auf Amazon zu verlassen?
Wenn du nur bei Amazon bestellst
und dir
die E-Mails von Amazon reichen, die du kriegst
und die Sendeverfolgung in Amazon
reicht, das ist okay,
dann brauchst du nichts anderes.
Allerdings, was man nicht vergessen darf, wirklich
ähm, eine ordentliche
Übersicht, wenn du nicht grad
die Amazon-App aufmachst auf deinem Tablet, hast du
nicht, ne? Also wenn du beispielsweise
irgendwie eine Heimautomatisierungslösung
hast und würdest gerne
wissen oder möchtest darauf reagieren,
wenn Pakete kommen und irgendwas machen,
dann geht das nicht, weil du kriegst es aus Amazon
nicht gescheit raus. Oder halt, du kannst
natürlich die Amazon-Seite parsen, das ist...
Aber so ist es auf jeden Fall praktischer,
weil du alle Anbieter drinne hast
und alle Shops, alle Shops
die E-Mails verschicken. Und jeder
Onlineshop verschickt, also
kennt ihr nen Onlineshop, der keine
E-Mail verschickt, wenn die Sendung aufm Weg ist?
Also mir fällt da keiner ein.
Der, der, der letzte
schlechteste
China-Shop
oder, oder
Inder-Shop bei Banggood
verschicken Bestätigungs-E-Mails.
Ja, der Name ist recht
unvorteilhaft, Banggood, geb ich zu.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben
bei dem Namen von dem Shop, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum man seine Seite Banggood nennt.
Aber ich mein,
die heißt halt nun mal so.
Banggood, Alter.
So, ähm,
was sagt uns dieses
JSON-Objekt? Das ist China-Logik.
Ich blicke da erstmal
überhaupt nicht durch.
Also, das da
ist wahrscheinlich der aktuelle
Stand der Sendung.
Das ist zuletzt aktualisiert.
B ist 0, C ist 0.
D und D sind leerer String.
Weil, L9
ist 0, L1 ist
wahrscheinlich
Ziel
Ziel, ähm,
Land
Darfst halt nur darauf hoffen, dass sich
die Namen in diesem JSON nicht ändern. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber immer noch besser
als HTML-Parsen.
So, und Z1
Z1 ist ein Array aus
den unterschiedlichen
Sendungs, ähm,
Events, Schritten.
Also, im Prinzip,
Beleg gerade, ähm,
Alter,
Donation hab ich schon ewig schon einmal gekriegt.
Donation.
Mr. Samu, hast du denn 2 Euro?
Sorry, das passt nicht zum Thema.
Glaubst du, du spielst wieder Overwatch?
Jetzt ist die
Nachricht weg.
Okay, Moment.
Oh, hier hab ich's. Sorry, das passt nicht zum Thema. Glaubst du,
du spielst wieder Overwatch?
Wenn die Rollenwahl rauskommt, habt ihr eine Overwatch?
Ich hab Overwatch-Videos mega gerne geschaut.
Ich hab's mir sogar schon installiert,
weil ich die Rollenqueue ausprobieren wollte.
Und ich dachte mir so, okay,
guckst du, guckst du
nochmal ein bisschen auf Twitch, dass du,
dass du vielleicht wieder so ein bisschen reinkommst.
Und das erste, was ich auf Twitch gesehen hab,
ist PussyP.
Und hab ich wieder aninstallt.
Weil ich schon ganz vergessen hab, wie kacke ich den
Modus fand.
Also, die Hermos-Seite schickt auch ein API-Request
raus nach Shipment-Search-Tracking-Nummer.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Das können wir uns auch noch angucken.
Aber
die Seite will ich eh als
Fallback haben. Also sollte mal irgendwie was
von den anderen Trackern nicht funktionieren,
ist sie als
Fallback wunderbar, weil die unterstützt einfach alles.
Ich hab immer noch so ein bisschen
Schwierigkeiten zu checken,
immer noch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten zu checken,
wie das Ganze
aufgebaut ist.
Was ist, was ist
9.1.2?
Z2?
6?
Okay, wir holen
uns erstmal Z0 raus.
Wir holen uns erstmal Z0 raus, weil
das ist der aktuelle,
der, der, der
zuletzt aktualisierte Eintrag
ist das, Z0.
Also der aktuelle Stand der Sendung
ist Z0.
Und ich denke mal, wenn wir einfach regelmäßig
abfragen, was wir ja machen,
ähm, ne, man lässt das ja eh
im Hintergrund laufen, so was weiß ich, einmal
eine Stunde oder, keine Ahnung, alle 30
Minuten oder so, oder einmal
am halben Tag, ist ja auch egal,
ähm, kriegen wir immer den aktuellsten
Stand mit, wie sich's aktualisiert, also eigentlich
brauchen wir diese History hier gar nicht.
Holen wir uns da mal
Z0 raus.
Also, was brauchen wir? Wir brauchen hier
DUT, DUT,
TRACK
und dann Z0.
Also, probieren wir mal.
DUT,
TRACK
und dann
Z0.
Und jetzt sollten wir nur die Daten
kriegen, die wir brauchen.
Huge Donation.
Äh, ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas falsch
gemacht, kann das sein?
Klar, oh, es hängt, es hängt.
Return 0, was
habe ich, was habe ich verkehrt gemacht?
Ach, nicht DATA,
DUT, einfach nur DUT.
Äh,
Donation, dankeschön, und zwar, wir haben ja da
5 Euro, Demonlord
Rimuru, schau dir schon
von Anfang an alles gut und bleib, wie du bist.
Hab ich vor.
Ähm, Leute,
auf Klo.
So, wieder am Start.
Stream ist zu Ende, nein, Stream ist nicht
zu Ende, ich war auf dem Klo.
Kack-FPS war es.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ähm,
also, wir haben jetzt unser Jason,
Jason raus gepasst aus
dem Kram, nochmal gucken, ob das auch funktioniert
jetzt. Äh,
Moment, ne, funktioniert nicht.
Was ist
falsch? Was ist
falsch? DUT Track?
Hab ich
verguckt.
Wir machen erstmal 30 Millionen Requests
an die China-Seite, dass wir gleich
gebannt werden. DUT ist
das hier? Track?
Ach, das ist ein Array, kein Object.
Nimm das Jason
und mach ne Klasse. Warum?
Für eine Sache, die ich
da draus brauche.
Jetzt geht das wahrscheinlich.
Ah, ha!
Jetzt funktioniert's.
Die Sendung wurde zugestellt, ähm,
2019 07 31
12 Uhr 14.
Perfekt. Kann ein bisschen
zackigere Musik haben.
Okay, ich glaub die Rechte sind nicht ganz hübsch.
Aber ich mein, wenn ich da jetzt ne Klasse machen
muss, dann brauch ich ne DUT-Klasse, irgendwie
ne, mit nem Array drinne und dann hat der
einen Track-Klasse und dann
dass er das deserializen
kann. Das ist Chill-Stab,
zum Chillen. Ja, ja, manchmal
sind die auch schon ein bisschen, bisschen zackiger, ja.
Hat halt nur low Beats.
Aber das ist, war ja teilweise
komplett zum Einschlafen gerade.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe,
haben wir jetzt das, ähm,
da drinne stehen
haben wir jetzt quasi,
ähm, Tracking-Info,
so nach dem Motto.
Und wie heißen die Dinger,
die ich da jetzt rausholen muss?
Z und A
brauch ich.
Also Z, Z ist quasi
die Message.
Die Sendung wurde zugestellt, quasi.
Und das ist die Zeit.
Ähm, und woher,
woher erkenn ich jetzt den Tracking-Status?
Ich mein, wir haben's ja hier,
wir haben's ja hier offen.
Woran erkenn ich jetzt den Tracking-Status?
Weil die wissen ja auch, hier ist es delivered.
Es ist delivered. Woher,
welcher dieser Zahlen bedeutet,
dass es delivered ist?
Gucken wir mal, Zahlen, die sich nicht ändern, ha?
Delivered.
Können wir vielleicht was gucken,
wenn wir die Klasse rausfinden von dem Ding?
Delivered.
Was könnte, was hiervon
könnte für
delivered stehen? Das da?
LN1? Dass das nicht
für Land steht, sondern für
delivered? Tracking-Stream.
Ja, manchmal muss man ein bisschen
reverse China-Hirn
denken.
Was ist das Land?
Aber warum gibt es Land 1, Land 2
und Land 9?
Sucht jemand eine Sendungsnummer, die noch nicht
delivered ist? Tja, hat jemand
eine Sendungsnummer, die noch nicht delivered ist?
Ich hätte noch eine andere Hermes-Nummer
zu bieten, nämlich die hier.
Gucken wir mal, was da drin steht dann.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall das Land.
Is1, Is2, vielleicht hat
irgendjemand schon sowas geschrieben.
The secret
API and how to use it.
Ach, guck mal.
Ha, POC.
Da haben Leute
schon ein bisschen rumgebastelt, wie es aussieht.
Ach, hier, guck mal.
Ach, guck mal, hier steht doch drin,
was es ist.
Da hat schon jemand die Arbeit für uns
gemacht. Return Code 1
ist okay, alles andere ist schlecht.
Big, big brain.
Message.
Return Code converted to text. Okay.
Ich glaube, das kriegen wir gar nicht.
Ich meine, das ist ein bisschen älter.
Das heißt nicht, dass es exakt noch so ist.
Ach doch, Message haben wir auch drin.
Ja doch, dann scheint es noch so zu sein.
Destination. C ist Destination.
Null. If it's a
non-international package. Ja, ist es ja.
Das ist ja von Deutschland nach Deutschland.
Package type.
Origin. B ist Origin.
B47, okay.
744 in Deutschland.
Package type D.
Gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Package Status E, das suchen wir.
E.
40. Package
Status 40.
Package State
Enum. In der Package State
Enum steht aber Country
Selection? Nee. Hm.
E.
Tja, wir haben keine Ahnung, was
für ein Status. 40?
40 wird
anscheinend delivered sein.
Problem ist, dass das hier nicht so drinnen steht.
Ach hier doch, Package States.
0,
10, 20, 30, 40, 50.
Ist das für ne komische
für
ne komische Logik, ey.
Also das ist
wirklich ne hässliche API, die sie
da gebaut haben.
Vor allem diese ganzen kryptischen Namen.
Na gut, die wollen ja nicht, dass man die verwendet.
Darf man nicht vergessen.
Package Status. Können wir uns doch gleich nochmal
rüber copy-pasten.
So, wir machen uns jetzt mal ne eigene
Klasse dafür.
Also.
Public Class.
Das ist der Track.
Ne, wie heißt das? 17, 17 Track.
Darf man überhaupt Zahlen am Anfang
haben? Nee, darf man nicht. Da denkt man, das ist ein Int.
Äh.
Ich brauch mal nen guten Namen für das Ding.
17 Track. Nee, äh.
Seven
Teen Track.
Seven, seven,
seven, teen Track.
Ey, wie nennen wir
das Ding jetzt? China Tracker.
Ne Klasse für Chess.
Erstmal ne Klasse, die das alles für mich macht.
Das steht ja aktuell alles in Main drinne und
und das ist
nicht so Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Public Class. Wir nennen das Ding
China Tracksor.
Erstmal gucken,
ob das überhaupt wirklich ein China Tracksor ist.
Haben die so
was wie nen...
Ja, das ist ein China Tracksor.
Okay.
China Tracksor.
China Tracker.
Okay. Der China Tracker
ist am Start. Nice.
Der Name gefällt mir nicht.
Aber ich lass es jetzt
erstmal so. Easy.
Ups. Okay.
Ähm. Dann.
Was?
Löscht der das?
Gut. Ähm.
Dann machen wir jetzt hier, keine Ahnung...
Track.
Mir fällt jetzt da nichts Sinnvolleres ein,
wenn wir das nennen sollen.
Der China Tracker trackt.
Huge Tracking.
Nice Tracking hat er hier.
Da kommt nämlich
der ganze Mist
kommt in den China Tracker rein.
Ähm.
Kommt hier weg.
Ja. Async.
Task.
So. Und nun
kann man das wieder in normalem Main machen.
Und
die Klasse
kommt in eigenen...
Machen wir mal ein eigenes File.
Ja.
Und mein China Tracker
ist fertig.
Wir räumen das jetzt noch ein bisschen auf.
So.
Es ist zumindest schon mal ein bisschen besser,
dass es nicht in Main rumgammelt.
Das ist richtig blöd. Das Benennen von
Dingern ist echt das Schwierigste.
Und ich finde es ist wichtig, dass man die Dinger...
Ich finde es wichtig, dass man
die Dinger ordentlich, ordentlich nennt.
So. Okay. Jetzt waren wir hier.
Wa.
Tracker.
China Tracker.
Track. So. Track kriegt jetzt natürlich
noch ne String.
Noch die äh...
Keine Ahnung.
Nummer von dem Ding.
Von dem Paket.
Und dann muss der eigentlich auch noch
den...
Den Name
vom Anbieter kriegen.
Das lassen wir aber erstmal weg.
Das muss ich nochmal gucken, wie wir das machen.
Ähm...
Der kriegt jetzt zumindest erstmal hier das da.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Immer noch. Immer noch funktioniert.
Geht. Nice.
Mainz Z0
ist kein guter Name.
Die Benahmung von dem ganzen Zeug
in der China API ist...
ziemlich wirr.
Übrigens, jetzt sieht man nämlich auch,
wenn ich das jetzt mal auf True stelle,
dann kann ich euch mal zeigen.
Das ist nämlich das Schöne daran.
Äh...
Ah doch, jetzt funktioniert es. Genau.
Das geht halt auch ohne, dass man ein Chrome Fenster
die ganze Zeit vor sich hat.
Also man kann das schon im Hintergrund
ordentlich machen.
Beendet der sich jetzt auch?
Chrome?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob der sich beendet,
wenn ich meine Anwendung beende.
Chrome? Da ist er. Da ist er. Hier ist er.
Was auch immer.
Der sah aber so aus, als hätte er sich beendet.
Okay, ähm...
nennen wir das mal...
Tracking Number.
Vom Paket ist das ja im Endeffekt.
So, dann brauchen wir einen enum.
Partial Class Program?
What?
Ach, weil ich das aus Versehen...
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich das inline geschrieben habe.
Statt irgendwo vergessen
Enter zu drücken.
Funktioniert immer noch.
Ähm...
Tracking Number, Tracking Number, Tracking Number
geht hier rein.
So, und jetzt brauche ich noch einen enum.
Den nennen wir jetzt mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Carrier oder so.
Ist Carrier ein sinnvoller Name dafür?
Ich meine, die nennen das so, aber
ich meine nur,
China-Übersetzung ist immer so eine Sache.
Aber ich glaube, Carrier trifft es
doch ganz gut, also was das halt für ein
Anbieter ist.
So, und was unterstützen wir in der aktuellen DHL?
Hermes...
Yes...
Was habe ich vergessen?
DPD, ne?
Genau, und da müssen wir uns jetzt merken,
dass Hermes
hat die ID
das da.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ähm...
Ob die alle
so formatiert sind, dass man die ordentlich
in einem enum verwenden kann.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Brauchen wir jetzt als enum, können wir noch Carrier
und dann sagen wir mal Hermes.
Das müssen wir in unserem Scanner rauskriegen,
ob das funktioniert.
Was ist denn ein enum?
Eine Liste? Ja, sowas, was
der Keokon schreibt.
Im Endeffekt ist das eigentlich nur eine
schönere Variante, wenn du
anstatt ins zu verwenden.
Ja...
Casten den mal zu einem int, weil
sonst weiß ich eigentlich gar nicht, was da dasteht an der Stelle.
So, funktioniert
das jetzt noch? Ja!
Nice, klappt.
Jetzt ist das Ganze nämlich auch ein bisschen lesbarer.
So ist jetzt der
Aufruf davon. Trackingnummer
und Carrier ist Hermes.
Jetzt können wir hier mal sagen, wait.
Dann mecker er auch nicht rum.
So, zack, bam, funktioniert.
Übrigens kann ich
mir dieses Press, Press, Dings to Exit sparen.
Weil er anscheinend
automatisch
schreibt.
Ach nee, das ist, wenn sich schon beendet
hat.
Dann lassen wir das mal doch drinnen.
Okay, der China-Tracker, der trackt.
Ich meine, das ist zwar nicht so hübsch an der Stelle,
jetzt müssen wir da draußen nur noch irgendwas basteln,
was sinnig ist.
Also, hier, genau.
Das wollten wir uns ja, das wollten wir uns ja
kopieren. Und zwar,
äh, wo habe ich es denn hier jetzt?
Nee.
Ach, hier.
Äh, genau. Package, Package
State brauchen wir noch.
Package, Package State.
Können wir eigentlich auch ein Enum draus machen.
Package State.
So, wow.
Ähm, was macht der denn da?
So, ähm, also
Package State ist
was haben wir hier?
Not found in
transit
ist 10.
Expired
ist 20.
Ready to be picked up
pick up
Nehmen wir das einfach nur. Ist 30.
Delivered
ist 40. Und dann haben wir, was ist denn
returned? Also, was soll
returned sein?
Egal. Returned
ist 50. Gut.
Ähm.
Da können wir das nämlich ordentlich
verwenden. Retoure.
Melde das
dir?
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das, bei der
Retoure kriegt das Ding doch eine neue Tracking-Nummer.
Ach so.
Ja, das kann sein.
Äh, nicht gefunden.
Also nicht zustellbar.
Pack doch die ganzen Sachen in ein
MD-File. Das ist tatsächlich Big Brain.
Aber, es reicht mir erstmal,
wenn ich mir das Book marke.
Wird schon nicht verschwinden. Hoffe ich mal.
Okay, dann können wir uns das jetzt an der Stelle
jetzt hier rausholen.
Ähm, und zwar
D
Ne, E
E ist
der State.
Der Status.
Der State, in dem Fall.
Vom
Paket. Also, brauchen wir
hier noch. Ähm.
State. Gucken wir mal.
Ähm. Was muss ich mir rausholen?
Track. Track.
E.
Track. E.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
9x Fatal 1347
40.
Ja, nice. Das klappt. Dann können wir jetzt nämlich
sagen, Package State
Pass. Ach ne, ähm.
Kann man
Kann man ein Int
Kann man ein Int direkt casten zu einem
Enum? Geht das?
Also, man kann ein Enum zu einem Int casten.
Das weiß ich. Aber kann man ein Int zu einem Enum
casten?
Muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Pase. Äh.
Wird so streng.
Ähm.
Kann man, kann man sowas hier machen?
Tatsächlich. Funktioniert.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie
ein Int zu einem
Enum gecastet, sondern immer nur Enums
zu einem Int. Ja, Enum ist schon.
Ich habe es bloß so rum noch nicht
gemacht.
Zumindest kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern. Oder wahrscheinlich ist es so
logisch, dass es geht, dass ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht habe.
Aber das ist nice.
So, das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen hässlich, das rum
gepase hier. Ist derjenige
noch da, der die ganze Zeit geschrieben hat,
ich soll eine Klasse fürs JSON-Pasen machen?
Ich glaube, das machen wir an der Stelle jetzt auch.
Müssen wir nur mal überlegen, wie die aussehen muss.
Irgendwie die aussehen muss.
Und wie ging das nochmal mit
JSON.NET Public Class?
Da haben wir das irgendwie,
Irgendwas. Tests.
Klar, mir fällt nichts ein. Ich muss erst mal gucken,
wie ich den Kram richtig benenne.
So, und da drinnen haben wir dann
ein Property Z0.
Was nen...
Ne, Z0, da steht
die ganze Info drinnen.
Wir brauchen eine Klasse, die
was enthält? Nicht Z0,
sondern
A, Z
und
A, Z und
E.
Ne, E und Z0.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das genau funktioniert.
Okay, wir können zumindest
hier den State, Package
State
und das Ding heißt E.
Die geile China-Api-Benahmung.
Ja, das ist ja nicht von
mir.
Ich weiß echt nicht, wie ich das Ding nennen soll.
Bleiben wir jetzt mal bei
Test Class. So, und jetzt sagen wir
nämlich mal hier, dass wir
JSON Convert
deserializen wollen.
Deserialize Object.
Nämlich eine Test Class,
die einen absolut beknackten Namen hat.
Und zwar...
Geht das sowas?
Kann ich da jetzt einfach
das da rein schieben?
Den Teil davon?
Ne.
Ich habe das hier
gemoppelt, gemoppelt.
Ich parse das, um es zu parsen dann.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Aber wir gucken mal, ob das
an sich funktioniert.
E.
Moppe das jetzt.
Delivered! Ah, okay.
Das funktioniert.
Das ist natürlich ganz praktisch.
Jetzt muss ich das nur noch hinkriegen,
dass ich das direkt parsen kann.
Hier oben das parsen kann.
Hat da jemand vielleicht schon ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung mit?
Weil ich will ja nicht jetzt
eine DUT-Klasse anlegen müssen,
eine TRACK-Klasse anlegen müssen.
Ähm...
Und sowas.
Ist eigentlich...
Wo ist auch mal Hilfeseite?
Deserialize.
Du packst hier eine Klasse List rein.
Jaja, ich bräuchte quasi
eine DUT-Klasse. Das meine ich ja.
Das ist eigentlich viel zu umständlich.
Ich will ja nur eine Sache haben.
Ich bräuchte quasi eine Klasse für DUT.
Und dann mach ich eine Liste rein.
Dann bräuchte ich allerdings...
Und dann da die...
...die Test-Class
noch mal eine Liste für Z0.
Website, um sich Sharp-Klassen aus
JSON zu generieren.
Och, des is cool.
Des is nice.
Ich glaub, des machen wir jetzt einfach mal damit.
Das heißt, da pastet man jetzt sein JSON rein.
Einfach, ne?
Oder?
Ach.
Wow.
Achso, des is die Decode-Klasse.
Ist gerade Swift. Moment.
Mockass.
Gibts da oben noch zur Auswahl.
Crystal, des is diese...
...Rubi-Rubi-Verschnitt.
C++.
C++ sieht natürlich mal wieder mit Abstand
am hässlichsten aus.
Muss so sein, ey.
Elm.
Elm is irgendwie...
Ich hab nix gesagt, des sieht noch schlimmer aus.
Ne, eigentlich gar nicht mal.
Eigentlich sieht des sogar ganz gut aus.
Die haben bloß die Angewohnheit,
das Komma vorne zu machen, anstatt's hinten.
Sieht gar nicht schlimm aus.
Des sieht ein bisschen aus wie Scala oder so.
Okay, doch, des sieht schon hässlich aus.
Ähm...
Flow.
Das is dieser...
Flow is doch der TypeScript...
...diese TypeScript-Geschichte von Facebook, ne?
...
Schau mal in die...
...Select-Token von J-Object rein.
Da kann man einen Pfad angeben und die bekommt dann den Wert.
Warte.
Okay.
Objektiv C.
Okay, das wird auch eklig aussehen.
Das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Objektiv C ist...
...abgrundtief hässlich.
Boah!
Alter!
Das ist das Schmerz beim Zugucken.
Das is...
...die richtige PPGA-Sprache, ja.
Boah!
Ne!
Ernsthaft, das is ja...
...richtig hängengeblieben.
...
so ein riesen ding damit kannst du alles irgendwie machen allerdings müssen wir
es ja gar nicht wirklich mit link query also mein wir wollen ja wir wissen ja
genau was verbrauchen im endeffekt kann man kann man mit select token da
irgendwie was dies hier realisieren lassen noch
übrigens danke für die ganzen follows ich sehe es hier gerade kam ein paar
rein hier den den wohl sie hat der ist gerade eben gefoltert aber den demon
lord muru noch donated da habe ich mir gemerkt da war irgendwie einprägsam
nobody cool die hei 45 nacht bot
das geht schiert für 90 bits habe ich ganz übersehen
kittro 2000 linux 418 das war schon war schon vor einem tag
und
da mehr sehe ich nicht dann soll nicht so viele heute weil ich sage ich finde
die sache hier eigentlich eine ganz ganz hübsche eine ganz hübsche variante
ich meine ich brauche ja im prinzip nur nur die paar klassen hier wie das ding
generiert das ist echt ganz nice das gefällt mir eigentlich die seite null
zuschauern eher das stimmt nicht ist die bettet von twitch sind gerade 91
was mich ein bisschen stört ist dass wir das hier oben einmal passen müssen
komplett um es dann zu und uns aus dem schon gepassten was rauszuholen wieder
umzuwandeln in den string um das dann wieder neu zu passen in ein objekt das
gefällt mir irgendwie nicht deswegen machen wir es wahrscheinlich einfach
einfach mit dem mit dem zeug hier
was ist das für ein paket?
towels
keine netzwerk pakete sind wir sprechen über abgaben passen und dann wissen wir dass das überhaupt nicht richtig ist
Okay, Parzels, ja, ist ja gut, Leute.
Ist ja gut, ey.
Euer Champ, ey.
Okay, ähm.
Da machen wir das anders.
Wir machen das wirklich so.
Wir machen uns eine Klasse hier von...
Wir machen uns einfach zwei Stück, das reicht ja.
Weil wir brauchen ja eh den ganzen anderen Mist nicht.
Wir brauchen auch nicht mal die Seite, die den Kram hier generiert.
You have the same voice as Overflow.
Okay.
You mean, ähm, live?
Live Overflow?
Very good channel.
He's on Twitch, too.
Ähm, okay, also.
Scott Yeven, danke für den Follow.
Okay, wir bauen das jetzt mal nach.
Also, ähm.
Wir brauchen jetzt als erstes DAT.
Total bescheuert, aber wir nennen es einfach mal DAT.
Weil die China-API der Meinung ist, das Ding heißt DAT.
Äh, da drinne gibt's dann eine Liste.
Mit.
Wo hab ich das nicht importiert?
Äh, da drinne gibt's dann eine Liste mit TRACK.
Dann nennen wir das hier auch TRACK.
TRACK.
So.
Ähm.
Das heißt doch einfach TRACK.
Lass mal weg.
Zack, zack.
Zack, zack, zack.
Woher die ganze...
So.
Ähm.
TRACK.
Dann haben wir hier Package State drinne.
In Package State.
In Package State haben wir dann.
Ne, hier in der TRACK-Klasse haben wir dann drinne.
Ein E.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz grandioser Name.
Ach ne, nicht E.
Ein Z0.
Was?
Warum haben die, warum nennen die das so beknackt?
So, Z0.
Ähm.
Z0 ist eine Liste.
Aus, ähm.
Wie nennen sie es hier?
Was?
Welcome.
Aus Z0.
Mit ABC.
Genau.
Wir bauen das jetzt mal nach von Hand hier.
Z0.
Dann nehmen wir halt auch eine Klasse, meinetwegen Z0.
Weil, Klasse aus Z0.
Eigentlich müssen wir das hier groß nennen.
Mal gucken, ob der Parser das checkt, wenn das so heißt.
TRACKS, nicht TRUNK.
Was?
Von was sprichst du jetzt?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Achso, TRACKS.
Nicht TRACK?
Doch, TRACK.
Passt.
Gut.
Das Ding muss so heißen, wie, ähm.
Also, hier muss das halt so heißen, dass er das findet.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
So, in Z0 gab's dann was?
In Z0 gibt's dann, gab's dann, ähm.
A und B oder irgendwie sowas, ne?
A, B, was gab's da?
A und Z ist das, was uns interessiert.
A.
Das ist der Timestamp.
Und wir nennen die Dinge auch gleich ordentlich.
Und Z, das ist der Text.
Wir, wir, wir geben den, wir geben den Dingern gleich ordentliche Namen.
Geben den Dingern gleich ordentliche Namen.
Wir gucken jetzt nur mal, ob's funktioniert.
Ähm, jetzt können wir nämlich einfach sagen.
Genau, Dings hier, JSON, Convert.
Convert.
Ähm, deserialize ein, ähm.
Ein was wollen wir deserializen?
Ein, ein DUT.
Ein DUT.
Und, ähm, ah, ich hab noch was vergessen.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Das kopieren wir uns jetzt einfach mal davon, weil ich keinen Bock hab, das nochmal selbst zu schreiben.
Die Welcome Class haben wir vergessen.
Die Welcome Class brauchen wir nämlich auch noch.
Funktioniert's nämlich net.
Wir wollen nämlich eine Welcome, wel...
Welcome deserializen.
So.
Body.
Gucken, ob das, ob das...
Wenigstens da nicht abkackt.
Ja.
Red.
Da müsste dann eins rauskommen, wenn's funktioniert.
Wow.
Äh.
Okay.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die ich wirklich jedem empfehlen kann.
Wenn ihr einen Fehler kriegt.
Schmeißt Sachen raus.
Und guckt, bis wohin es funktioniert und bis wohin nicht.
Das hier, das funktioniert nämlich.
Der hat also Schmerzen.
Beim deserialisieren von dem anderen Zeug.
Okay, G brauchen wir nicht.
Genau.
Der hat Probleme beim deserialisieren von...
Anscheinend von DUT.
Wahrscheinlich hat er Probleme damit, weil ich den Kram groß anstatt klein genannt hab.
Wir sind jetzt mal so.
Wir sagen einfach Object.
Dann kann er da reinschreiben, was er will, ohne dass ich eine Klasse anlegen muss.
Hoffe ich.
Glaub ich.
Fuck.
Äh.
Can't...
Into Track.
Because JSON Array.
Also in Track kann er das nicht machen.
In Track.
Warum nicht?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Okay, das funktioniert.
Was, er kann Lists nicht deserialisieren?
Warum nicht?
Kann er auch sogar hier einstellen, dass er eine List verwenden soll?
Er kann bestimmt eine List deserialisieren.
Garantiert.
Das wäre doch bescheuert, wenn er das nicht könnte.
Benutzt JSON Property Annotation.
Das mache ich gleich.
Das muss aber auch so funktionieren.
Da kann ich die Dinger nämlich ordentlich benennen.
Ne?
Also man sieht, dass es nicht an der Liste liegt, weil List Object funktioniert.
Oh.
Warum?
Okays.
Hieß der Kram nicht Track?
Ach, der hieß Track.
Kleingeschrieben, ne?
Track.
Das muss mit einer Liste funktionieren.
Warum soll das mit einer Liste nicht funktionieren?
Because the type requires a JSON Array to see.
Warum soll er das dann mit einer Liste nicht können?
Warum nicht?
Ja, aber warum...
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Oh, hä?
Warum nicht?
Warum kann er da...
Warum kann er keine Liste?
Das ist doch scheißegal, ob das ein Array ist oder eine Liste.
Weil die Lib kacke ist.
Ne, die Lib ist nicht kacke.
Das ist...
Die größte und verbreiteste JSON Library für... für .NET eigentlich.
Die ist normalerweise nicht kacke.
Übrigens, ASP.NET Core 3 kriegt eine eigene... eine eigene JSON Implementierung.
Die verwenden kein JSON .NET mehr.
Ja.
Der Morpheus freut sich.
Der Morpheus420.
Oder hast du gerade 420 gemacht, dass... dass du so gut drauf bist?
Nein hehehe
Ochmanscheine.
Ach, ich hab... guck, hab ich schon wieder eine Liste drin.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Wir benennen den Kram jetzt erstmal richtig.
Also, ähm, jason.property.
So, und das Ding soll heißen.
Track.
Wir nennen es Tracks.
Ah, da kann man das nämlich ordentlich
C-Sharp-Style machen. Da freut sich auch der
weiß nicht wer es geschrieben hat, irgendjemand
hat gesagt, er will das unbedingt mehr
zahlenmäßig haben. Tracks or
Honker Smoke.
Was kann das Ding eigentlich noch?
Was haben wir da noch für Dinger?
Property Name
is Reference
Item Converter Parameters
was auch immer. Converter
Name
Strategy Parameters
was auch immer für Zeug, ey.
Naming Strategy. Achso, da kann man sagen, wahrscheinlich
ähm, ob
Uppercase, Camel Case,
Kebab Case oder was auch immer.
Äh, Object Creation Handling
oder
Okay, das ist jetzt nichts, was für uns so
relevant ist.
Ja,
Kiokon, das ist sowas. Ja.
Oder wie ein Object C.
Das ist auch Ad-Zeichen.
Objekt C, ja.
Sibaro Case.
Okay, Track.
Jetzt finde ich das bescheuert, warum
Scythe, nennen wir das.
Das nennen wir Message.
Result.
Aber wir nennen das, ne, wir nennen das nicht
Status Code, nennen wir das.
Ist viel besser.
Ähm, dann haben wir da drinnen
einen Dat.
Ich denke, du musst die Liste...
Ach, meinst du?
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Das probiere ich gleich mal, wenn es jetzt noch funktioniert.
Was habe ich jetzt wieder kaputt gemacht?
Alter, meine Fresse, ey.
Ähm.
Wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Wo ist das Problem? Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen, ey?
Was?
Was habe ich jetzt kaputt gemacht?
Ich habe doch eigentlich gar nichts geändert, oder?
Du hast immer noch Object.
Ja, aber das muss doch funktionieren.
Es muss doch mit Object,
das muss doch funktionieren.
Hat doch eben auch funktioniert.
Wartet mal, Leute.
Ich mache den Kram mal gerade wieder rückgängig.
Hat doch eben auch funktioniert.
Was?
Das ging doch eben. Aber ich bin gerade echt, echt verwirrt.
Paste Special.
Was willst du mir sagen, Morpheus? Paste Special.
Was?
Paste Special.
Paste Chasen S-Classes.
Hä?
Ah!
Okay, das ist eine coole Funktion.
Die kann ich nicht.
Aber mir geht es voll auf den Sack.
Warum ging das denn eben nicht?
Wir haben das doch eben schon mal mit Object ausprobiert.
Object muss doch funktionieren.
Eins. Genau.
Add.
Object.
Nice. Geht auch.
Okay.
List.
Ich probiere das nämlich nochmal.
Object.
Das geht jetzt nicht.
Das geht jetzt kaputt, ne?
Warum geht das denn jetzt?
Oder macht er das dann einfach nicht?
Warum geht das denn jetzt auf einmal mit der Liste an der Stelle und vorher nicht?
Ich blicke, ich checke das gerade irgendwie nicht.
Also das ist irgendwie...
Wir.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, ich muss sowas hier machen.
Das funktioniert.
Oh.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt das da mal weg.
Sagen einfach nur Class.
Dat.
Geht es wahrscheinlich wieder nicht.
Doch.
Funktioniert es.
Warum genau ging das voll...
Kann mir das irgendjemand sinnvoll schlüssig erklären?
Das ging doch eben auch noch nicht.
Okay.
You got debated.
Der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich mit irgendwas rumspacken.
Jawoll.
Cannot deserialize kernel into track because the type requires a JSON-Array.
Okay.
Aber wir haben doch ein Array.
Ich check das nicht.
Wo ist denn das Problem jetzt?
Habe ich irgendwas...
Moment.
Ach Moment.
Wartet mal.
Ähm.
Wir sehen uns jetzt an der Stelle nochmal so aus.
Wo ist...
Hä?
Warte mal.
Das ist dat.
Dat.
Element 0.
Und da drinnen ist dann track.
Aber track ist kein...
Track ist kein...
Kein Array.
Oder keine List.
Ne?
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Haha.
Ja.
Dachte nur das ist...
Das ist gar kein Array.
Das ist ein ganz normales Object.
Also da ist...
Da muss ja nichts geindexed werden oder so.
Jetzt wird das wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren.
Jetzt kann ich nämlich so sagen.
Zack.
Track.
Mal hier.
Ups.
Easy.
Ja.
Jetzt funktioniert das nämlich auch.
Track.
Packet State.
Dann lassen wir uns jetzt Packet State anzeigen.
First.
Gut.
So.
Dat.
At.
Null.
Track.
E.
E ist Packet State.
Delivered.
Genau das was wir im Endeffekt wollen.
So.
Das ding heißt Statuscode.
Das ding heißt Message.
Das ding heißt Dat.
Dat ist ein total bescheuerter name dafür.
Kann man dem Ding jetzt nicht hier drinnen irgendwie sagen.
Das er dort.
Das er.
dass er dort das erste
hier, also
dass der nicht den Array aus dat
macht, was komplett sinnlos ist, weil dat
gibt es ja hier eigentlich auch nur
einmal. Aber dat
ist ein
Array,
allerdings ein Array mit
nur einem Element drin.
Kann man dem hier jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen,
ich hätte gerne
dat raus, das erste
Element und dann track direkt
da rein? Geht das vielleicht?
Was ist, wenn man jetzt
die Arrays wie den Listen ändert?
Gute Idee, probieren wir mal aus.
List dat.
Ja, funktioniert.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß nicht, was das
vorher war mit den Listen und Arrays, die nicht
funktionieren haben, aber
das kann er. Easy.
Oh, der Chillstep
Mix ist vorbei, was haben wir jetzt hier?
Beautiful Chillstep.
Beautiful.
Kann man dem jetzt das hier sagen, dass der das da rausnehmen
soll?
Type
Item Converter
Type. Ja, damit könnte ich das wahrscheinlich
machen, da müsste man einen eigenen Converter
programmieren, aber das ist unsinnig.
Dann machen wir es halt so.
Dann haben wir halt eine dat
Liste und in dat einen track
und im track
dann einen
aber ich würde es nicht gerne dat
nennen, wir nennen es mal zumindest hier data.
Tracking
Tracking Data, hä?
Nennen wir es mal so.
Tracking Data.
Oder was Tracking Info oder so nennen.
So, ähm.
Dann nennen wir das hier Tracking.
Dat.
Ähm.
Track, Track, Track ist okay.
Mein Track ist eigentlich
ein Scheißname dafür.
So, Package State. Package State
nennen wir auch Package State.
Mittlerweile hat ja Visual Studio da ganz
gute Vorschläge automatisch für.
So, Package State.
Was?
Ach so, ja, hier.
Track.
Package State.
So, da soll jetzt wieder Delivered rauskommen, wenn alles funktioniert.
Ja, Delivered.
Das ist doch jetzt schon mal deutlich, deutlich
schicker, oder? Als der Mist vorher.
Tracking Data.
Null. Track.
So. Und da drinnen gibt es jetzt
noch die
einzelnen Informationen, wo
die Sendung gerade ist.
Ähm, das Ding,
das ist dann Z0.
List aus.
Ups. Als Shortcut.
List aus, ähm.
Z0.
Gucken wir, ob es wenigstens funktioniert.
Anscheinend.
Aber A und Z.
So, ähm.
A war, äh, ähm.
Timestamp, ne?
Das ist die Baro, ja.
Du kannst sie, falls du die Leute aus Versehen
random bannst, kannst du sie ja auch wieder entbannen.
Aber entbannen dann nicht random.
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht, das funktioniert dann, glaube ich, nicht.
Ähm, und Z war...
Was mache ich denn hier?
Nicht Timestamp. A war das und Z.
Ähm.
Das hier war die Message, irgendwie so. Message.
Äh, die Message
ist anscheinend immer auf Deutsch, weil
Hermes die Sachen auf Deutsch
raushaut.
Also, können wir uns jetzt da mal rausholen?
Package state?
Sondern hol uns da
Z0
Da braucht man auch noch ordentlichen
ordentlichen Namen für.
Z0
Da holen wir uns da mal den Timestamp.
Öh!
Weil?
Weil gar keine Liste ist, oder?
Wieder. Ist das wieder das
gleiche Problem? Ich glaube das ist wieder das gleiche
Problem.
Das gleiche Problem. Ich hab den...
Ha! Zack!
Funktioniert.
Man kann das Zeug ja schon wenigstens halbwegs lesen.
Nur dass ich das nicht Z0 nennen will.
Das heißt, Tracking Data Track.
Das sieht man mal, wie merkwürdig diese China-AP ist an der Stelle.
Tracking Data ist komplett überflüssig.
Vielleicht ist das sinnvoll, wenn es eine Sendung ist mit mehreren Paketen.
Das könnte sein, dass es quasi eine Sendung ist, die mehrere Pakete enthalten kann.
Dann ist das hier nämlich quasi so das Package.
Wenn ich die China-Logik richtig verstehe.
Das ist quasi das Package da drin.
Was ist denn da noch drin gewesen?
In DAT.
Ne, nicht in DAT.
Doch, in DAT.
Was ist denn sonst noch in DAT drin?
Ne, nix.
Delay.
Delay, ja, wen juckt's.
Number.
Die wissen wir, die haben wir selbst eingegeben.
Da ist irgendwie noch ein G drin.
Und eigentlich nix interessantes, so wirklich.
So, und Z0 ist dann quasi so der aktuelle Stand vom Paket.
Warum?
Warum haben die das eigentlich noch mal als Unterklasse hier gemacht?
Die hätten das doch ohne Probleme in Track mit reinschreiben können.
Z0, Z1, Z2, Z9?
Das ist Mindblown China-RP irgendwie.
Voll wir gemacht.
Man merkt daran, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, wie man den Kram überhaupt nennen soll.
Dann ist das, das ist dann quasi Detail, so Package Detail oder so.
So, hä?
Das, das liest sich jetzt zumindest schon mal nicht mehr ganz so wie.
Ah, du hast hier quasi nen, äh, wieso ist hier, ist das eine Antwort?
Da drin ist Tracking Data.
Du nimmst den ersten, das erste Element aus Tracking Data.
Ich mein, es hat im Prinzip immer nur 0, aber okay.
Da drin nimmst du dann das, das, das Paket und dann lässt du die Package Details anzeigen.
Welcome ist kein geiler Name, ja, das stimmt.
Da muss ich mir noch was einfallen lassen.
Wie, Response oder so.
Ähm, und da drin dann Timestamp.
Das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut.
So, in Message sollte dann drinne stehen, das Paket ist, ist angekommen.
Oder auch nicht.
Moment, das ist ja auch nicht Z, oder?
Das war, die Sendung wurde zugestellt, sollte da auch drinne stehen.
Warum steht das da nicht?
Timestamp.
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Ich glaub, die API ist grad abgekackt.
Die hat grad nicht geantwortet.
Die Sendung wurde zugestellt.
Ich find's schon mal doof, dass der Timestamp nen String ist.
Ich, so ne Custom Converter wär auch ganz cool.
Was ich jetzt quasi sagen könnte, kann man, das wär doch nice, wenn man hier irgendwie sowas machen könnte, wie Convert oder so.
Ja.
Dass man da jetzt angeben könnte,
dass da quasi direkt den,
wie er den, den String in den, in den Timestamp umwandeln soll, weil ich glaube nicht, dass das so funktioniert.
Ne.
Das könnte jetzt übrigens an der China-AP liegen, die nicht richtig antwortet.
Weil, weil wenn das nicht geht, wird's doch ne Exception geben, oder?
Also mal angenommen, das würde, würde sich nicht umwandeln lassen, dann müsste es ja doch ne Exception geben und nicht einfach nur nichts.
Na ja.
Schön, Console-Log-Debugging.
Der kann das umwandeln? Von Haus aus?
Krass.
Das hätt ich nicht gedacht, dass der den Zeitstempel in nen .NET-Daytime-Object ordentlich umwandeln kann.
Wär dir das gedacht? Das hätt ich nicht gedacht.
.NET-Magic, ja.
White-Pepo-Pock, wusste ich gar nicht, dass ich den hinzugefügt hab.
Aber Chris W. hat ihn trotzdem entdeckt.
Sag mal, Chris W., kann das sein, dass wir mal Overwatch gespielt haben in der Beta?
Wie kommt der Name jetzt schon wie bekannt vor, aber es kann auch einfach sein, dass es mehrere Chris W.s gibt.
Cool, ne Tracking-App mit Archivierung, ja.
Mit Archivierung und vor allem Notification, wenn das Paket auch am Start ist.
Okay, ich bin begeistert, dass der den Zeitstempel einfach umwandeln kann.
Ich hab gedacht, ich muss wahrscheinlich jetzt irgendwie so nen Custom-Converter oder irgendwas, äh, konvertier, irgendwie irgendwas basteln, dass der das automatisch, weil das er automatisch nicht kann.
Was hast du eigentlich zum Geburtstag bekommen?
Äh, ziemlich langweiliges Zeug.
Paar Schraubenzieher, Schraubendreher, ja.
Ähm, paar Kisten.
So ein kleines Regal.
Äh, nix Wildes, ja.
Ich will ja eigentlich auch gar nix Großartiges haben.
Ich wurde heute hart getrollt von meinem, was?
Ich wurde heute hart von meinem neuen Mainboard getrollt.
Aber übrigens, wenn wir grad bei der Sache sind, äh, mit was ich zum Geburtstag bekommen hab.
Ihr könnt mir natürlich gerne alle eure Twitch Prime Subs dalassen.
Denn, falls ihr's noch nicht wusstet, wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt, könnt ihr den kostenlos mit eurem Twitch-Account verknüpfen.
Dafür gibt's dann monatlich neues Twitch Prime Loot und ihr könnt einem Streamer eurer Wahl einmal im Monat einen kostenlosen Sub dalassen, der euch nix kostet.
Allerdings für den Streamer zählt das genauso wie ne ganz normale Redakteur.
Sellout-Mode
activated.
So, ist ganz schön spät schon, ne?
Ja, Welcome hat noch einen ziemlich dummen Namen.
Den nennen wir
nicht Welcome, sondern
Up.
Ich würd's...
Wie nennen wir das?
War ne glorreiche Idee.
Infobox?
Ne, das ist kein guter Name für das Ding.
Ähm.
Api-Status?
Ich bin
kein Fan da großartig
mehrere Sachen, also
die Sachen unnötig
Status oder Info
oder so zu nennen, weil das kann sich
immer kein Mensch merken, was das eigentlich sein soll.
Response?
Ich,
eigentlich will ich die
Infos gar nicht, ne?
Generiere einfach einen zufälligen Namen.
Ich facerolle jetzt.
China-Response.
Ah, das ist schlecht.
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, wie ich den Kram nennen soll.
Wut-Face.
Alter.
Funktioniert. Perfekt.
Die haben einfach auf den Namen gewartet.
So, wunderbar. Also China-Api.
China-Api abgreifen.
Funktioniert ganz gut.
Die Sendung wurde zugestellt.
Wir kriegen jetzt hier verschiedene Infos drüber,
ob das ganze Ding
in transit ist, expired ist,
delivered ist.
Es ist nicht Package-Detail, es ist, ähm...
Eigentlich ist es ja...
Null.
Eigentlich ist das, ähm...
Nicht Package, das ist der, der aktuelle,
der aktuelle Status
von diesem Paket.
Aber ich, wir müssen es jetzt nicht so übertreiben.
Passend der Name, ja, das stimmt.
Also,
die China-Api ist schon sehr wir.
Vielleicht fällt mir da noch irgendwas Besseres ein.
Belassen wir es erstmal hierbei.
Das kann man jetzt halbwegs lesen.
Ähm, mir fällt grad ein,
das ist ziemlich...
ziemlich blöd hier oben gemacht,
eigentlich, weil
ich ruf das ja so auf.
Ich sag hier Track, Tracking-Nummer und, ähm...
Naja, halt, dass es Hermes ist.
Und...
Das wäre ja
denkbar.
Ich muss das ja irgendwie, also ich muss ja irgendwie
das hier wieder returnen, ne?
Ich muss ja irgendwie die Infos
zurückgeben an der Stelle.
Es bringt ja nichts, wenn ich die Standard-Out,
wenn ich die auf die Konsole
raushaue.
Ich muss das ja irgendwie,
irgendwie zurückgeben, so.
Und,
wenn ich das,
wenn ich das hier unten
drinne generiere,
kann es durchaus schon sein,
dass das hier komplett disposed ist
und der hier raus ist.
Das ist irgendwie nicht so ganz Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Da muss ich mir was einfallen lassen.
Da muss ich warten.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall warten,
bis der Kram
verarbeitet ist.
Und ich muss aus dem Event,
also ich muss jetzt hier irgendwie sowas sagen,
wie, ähm,
hier warten,
bis Event sagt,
okay, so nach dem Motto.
Also ich brauchte jetzt irgendwie so ein Reset
oder so einen, so einen, ähm,
irgendein Reset-Event oder sowas
brauch ich an der Stelle.
Naja, weil es kann ja sein,
dass, ähm,
ich hier drinne gerade am verarbeiten bin,
weil ich meine, das ist ja Async.
Und das hier eigentlich schon durch ist, ne?
Zumal,
zumal ich will ja am Ende,
ähm,
Async void,
ja, ne, das ist,
ne, Async void ist in dem Fall schon okay.
Das muss void sein,
weil das Event halt,
kann, ich krieg ja da nichts raus da an der Stelle.
Kann da glaube ich gar nicht Task reinschreiben,
oder? Dann zählt's nicht.
Ne, dann geht's nicht.
Logischerweise, weil das, das muss ja vom,
von den Parametern her passen,
zum, zum Händler,
was der haben will. Ähm,
also,
aber hier will ich ja eigentlich kein
Task zurückgeben. Eigentlich
will ich an der Stelle gar nichts Asynchrones
machen. Weil wozu?
An der Stelle?
Ja, wobei, doch, ich kann was Asynchrones
machen, aber ich muss an der Stelle,
muss ich eigentlich meine, meine Dings hier
zurückliefern, mein, mein, sag ich mal,
Package oder so, nennen wir's mal.
Das muss ich an der Stelle zurückliefern.
Ähm, ich mach jetzt
einfach mal so, dass ich weiß, dass es nicht funktioniert, aber nur, dass es
nicht kompiliert. Das heißt,
ich muss hier warten.
Ich muss hier warten, bis das
Event
den Kram gesetzt hat.
Dann
würde ich sagen,
brauchen wir sowas wie
Manual,
oh, wie heißt's?
Manual Reset Event.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Set off.
So what, so what
are we doing here exactly?
Ähm,
we build, äh,
shipment tracking
app.
And currently we try to, ähm,
get, äh,
information
from a Chinese
tracking website
and fight with the
Chinese RP, API
because they use
very good naming conventions
like BCE
and
W1 and 2.
Äh, while Chinese
shipment tracking, äh,
it's only for backup. Ähm,
I want to support the
four major German
shipment, äh,
carriers.
And if
they fail, I want to use
this site as backup.
And it has no official RP,
no official API,
ähm,
we need to remote control
a Chrome browser and,
ähm, fish the
JSON and sniff the
JSON from the request
and extract
the information we need, ähm,
but it has very bad naming.
But it already
works.
We get the message,
the last known message from this
shipment and the
timestamp
when it was delivered.
Zugestellt
means delivered in
German.
It's only available in German because it's a
German, German carrier.
Ähm, äh,
to get the JSON, you need to remote control
Chrome.
You can use this, ähm,
puppeteer sharp library.
You need to create a new
browser and set it
headless, set headless to true.
Ähm, if you set it to false,
you can see the actual
browser window, what it does
and it's finished.
If you
set headless to true, you can't see it, so
you can run it in the background
while the user is using
your app.
Ähm,
you need to create a browser, you need to
create a new tab in the browser
and you need to
subscribe to the event, to an
event which is
triggered on every
response the browser receives.
Then we
ähm, check if the
domain that is
used in this response is the
internal Chinese tracking
API. If it
is, we extract the
we extract the string from
from the body of the web page
and ähm,
build JSON
objects from it. And we
modeled the
very nice, äh, Chinese
API calls.
Like a red message
dot track e
z1 äh
z0 a z
äh, and it works. It
gives us the last timestamp,
the message
and if we execute it every
30 minutes in the background
we can save it and äh
know
when it has been updated and we can
send a notification. The plan is
to use an ähm
ähm
äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh ä
Und manche, wie Hermes, bieten keine offizielle API.
Also müssen wir mit Magie zusammenarbeiten, um es zu funktionieren.
Kennt ihr irgendwelche Pentesting-Tools?
Nur die normalen Linux-Tools? Nichts Besonderes?
Ach, das war Englisch. Ja, Leute. Omega-Lol.
Ach, übrigens, weil ich ganz am Anfang wusste, dass die Leute in Frankfurt immer fertiger werden im Kopf.
Ich habe noch was vergessen, was dazu zu erzählen.
Das erzähle ich jetzt auch, weil es 22.30 Uhr ist. Ich glaube, ich muss gleich demnächst noch mal pennen gehen.
Ich habe ja am Anfang erzählt, die werden immer fertiger in Frankfurt, um den Hauptbahnhof herum.
Und ich habe die Vermutung, das liegt daran, dass die sich andere Drogen reinhauen als früher.
Die aggressiver machen. Und wo sie nicht komplett in den Seilen hängen.
Und ich hatte mal, ich musste mal Blut abnehmen gehen.
Also normalerweise sagt da nie einer was.
Da sagt nie einer irgendwas, die hängen alle nur in den Seilen.
Oder sind teilweise aggressiv heutzutage.
Und ich musste mal Blut abnehmen gehen.
Und ich habe eingewilligt, dass der Azubi das machen darf beim Doktor. Blut abnehmen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, in welcher geistigen Umnachtung ich mich da irgendwie befunden habe.
Aber ich habe gesagt, ah ist okay.
Das war aber auch ein Azubi-Grill.
Wahrscheinlich wollte ich irgendwie nicht so weichlich aussehen und sagen, ich lasse das nicht machen vom Azubi oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest habe ich da zugestimmt, das von der Azubi machen zu lassen.
Und die hat es halt verkackt. Die hat nicht richtig beim Blut abnehmen drauf gedrückt.
Und da hatte ich halt so Blut quasi komplett.
Wenn du nicht richtig drauf drückst, dann läuft es halt so ein bisschen in den Arm.
Du hast so einen Bluterguss, so den halben Arm runter.
Da war der ganze Arm unten rot und blau.
Und da bin ich dann am anderen Tag durch Frankfurt durchgelaufen.
Und auf einmal begrüßt mich so einer von den Junkies, die da in der Ecke hocken, so voll freudig.
Ja, hi, wie geht's?
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, was ist mit dem los?
Ich hätte jetzt von dem nicht erwartet, dass der nett zu mir ist.
So, weil normalerweise sitzen die immer in der Ecke und schreien rum, Alter, verpiss dich.
Oder irgendwas, ja, und sagen nichts.
Und bis mir es dann danach gedämmert ist, ja.
Danach ist mir es gedämmert.
Der hat gedacht, ich gehöre dazu und habe vielleicht was übrig.
Das hat er sich gedacht.
Der hat meinen Arm gesehen und hat sich gedacht, der hat bestimmt was.
Weil sonst sagen die nie was, nie.
Es hat nie wieder, also nie davor und nie wieder danach.
Einer hat was gesagt.
Big Brain, ja.
Übrigens habt ihr mitbekommen, AVM hat heute Nachmittag den Telefonsupport eingestellt.
Die sind abgesoffen vor Regen.
Was, echt?
Hast du das nicht mitgekriegt?
Gibt es da News zu?
Eventuell hatte der Dude auch einfach mal einen guten Tag.
Ich weiß nicht.
Dann wäre er echt herausragend, einzigartig gewesen.
Also wie gesagt, sonst hat nie jemand was.
Hast du die Nummer vor dem Grill?
Alter, die Leute.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass die wahrscheinlich halb so alt ist wie ich.
Facebook-AVM-Page.
Aufgrund von starken und damit verbundenen Schäden mussten wir soeben leider die Support-Outline abschalten.
Oh, da ging es aber wohl echt ab.
Da scheint es abgegangen zu sein.
Bei AVM.
Ja gut, aber wird nichts Wildes sein.
Hat halt gepisst.
MonkaStrike.
MonkaSmoke.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass MonkaSmoke dann bei AVM am Start ist.
Weil ich brauche in...
Das ist der zweite.
Ich brauche in 20 Tagen eine neue Fritzbox.
AVM darf jetzt nicht abkacken.
Ist nicht erlaubt.
Eine neue Kabel-Fritzbox, genau.
SilentPain schreibt, sein Kollege PC ist kaputt gegangen.
Wegen Blitzanschlag.
Aha.
Das habe ich auch selten gesehen.
Dass das wirklich mal passiert.
Ich habe meinen PC auch gar nicht an irgendeine Überspannungsgeschichte dran.
Aber ich habe ein ordentliches Netzteil.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und...
Moin Elinas90.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und das Netzteil fängt es ab.
Ich hätte ja ein paar Steckdosenleisten mit Überspannungsschutz.
Aber habe ich nicht dran.
Das einzige, wo ich das dran habe, ist halt an meinem Rack.
Über die USV.
Die hat einen Überspannungsschutz.
SilentPain, da kann man sich schon mal erschrecken.
Laufen Gewitterschäden nicht über die Hausratsversicherung?
Naja, selbst wenn, ist es halt nervig einfach nur.
Wenn ein Rechner abkackt.
Vielleicht hast du auch jetzt nicht...
Vielleicht bist du auch nicht unbedingt der eifrigste Backup-Macher.
Und deine SSD hat es zerrissen.
Das ist...
Da bringt die Versicherung nur die halbe Sache bei.
Ey, das stimmt, ja.
Wobei mir die Kosten fast nicht so wichtig wären.
Sondern eher...
Also der Aufwand drumherum wäre viel nerviger.
Aber...
Ich meine...
Wenn es ein teurer Rechner ist, ist es natürlich schon mal gut.
Wenn man dann nicht irgendwie auf 2000€ sitzen bleibt.
Das stimmt schon.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, ob Blitzschläge abgedeckt sind.
Aber ich vermute mal schon.
Sbarro, das ist eine gute Idee.
Backup kann nicht schaden.
Zumal das Gute ist...
Wenn man ein ordentliches Backup-Programm verwendet...
Ähm...
Dann...
Moment, was macht meine Tastatur?
Wenn man ein ordentliches Backup-Programm verwendet, dann geht das auch schnell, wenn man regelmäßig Updates macht.
Dann machst du ja nur den Diff dazu.
Und dann auch, wenn du halt ein ordentliches Backup-Programm hast, was das Ganze noch komprimieren kann.
Deduplicated.
Dann...
Geht das schnell und braucht kaum Speicher.
Wenn du quasi jeden Tag ein inkrementelles Backup machst.
Oder einmal in der Woche ein inkrementelles Backup machst.
Das braucht nicht viel.
AirSync für Backups.
Ja, AirSync oder was ich richtig gut finde, ist halt das hier.
Das da.
Das ist halt...
Für mich das beste Backup-Programm, was es gibt.
Ich meine, es kann...
Es ist nicht so einfach in der Bedienung, wie das vielleicht jetzt irgendwie...
Ähm...
Hier Acronis True Image ist oder sowas.
Falls der Sibaro gerade geschrieben hat.
Wo du einfach eine GUI hast, was anklickst.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht so einfach damit...
Sagen wir zum Beispiel so komplette Festplatten-Snapshots zu machen.
Wo du danach einfach sagen kannst...
Ich boote von einem Live-Stick und mache Recover und das System ist wieder da.
Aber es ist halt super.
Für alles andere.
Das hat die...
Das hat Compression.
Deed-Application.
Du kannst es über SSH verwenden.
Ähm...
Das ist von Haus aus verschlüsselt mit allen möglichen...
Also Optionen.
Also sprich...
Mit Passwort, mit irgendeinem Key auf einem USB-Stick oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Ähm...
Du kannst das...
Du kannst das Backup...
Kannst du mounten und dann halt mit den Standard-Linux-Tools durchsuchen, öffnen...
Ähm...
Angucken, weil du weißt ja nicht immer genau, wo eine Datei gelegen hat, die du jetzt suchst aus dem Backup.
Also das ist...
An sich ist das...
Ist das wirklich das beste Backup-Tool, was ich kenne.
Ja.
Okay, Leute.
Also es ist jetzt 22.40.
So langsam aber sicher...
Müsste ich dann echt mal auf, ne?
Ich glaube Samstag...
Samstag ist halt...
Äh...
Freitagabend ist tatsächlich auf Twitch nicht so viel los.
Der ist ja immer noch an seiner Wasserkühlung.
Der hat doch schon...
Der hat schon von über ner...
Über ner Woche...
Angefangen mit der Wasserkühlung.
Der ist ja wieder der...
Der...
Das ist doch der...
Der von Unge ist das doch da.
Inventar, Track & Drop-Verbesserung.
Haha!
Er hat mal nen Zuschauer!
Guck mal, Leute.
Der...
Sebaru ist mir auch gerade aufgefallen.
Der Wirtschafts-Stream hat mal einen Zuschauer.
Wahrscheinlich ist er das selber.
Und er hat...
Und der 3D-Printer ist kaputt.
Der 3D-Printer-Stream ist kaputt.
Und der 3D-Printer-Stream ist kaputt.
Oder einfach nur die Lampe aus.
Wir machen morgen weiter.
Mit der China-API.
Und da fangen wir auch ein bisschen früher an.
Hast du mit Manjaro-architekt18 diesen Error gehabt?
Nein.
Ich...
Wo ich das L...
Manjaro zuletzt installiert, hab ich im Stream hier für...
Für die...
für diese VM. Das ist aber auch schon
wieder zwei Jahre her. Brauchst du doch
Ninja auf Mixer?
Ich hab vorhin Seagull... Ne.
Ne. Wen hab ich vorhin geguckt?
Nicht Seagull?
Deathrun. Unseren
McDonalds-Man hab ich vorhin geguckt.
Und da hat im Chat die ganze Zeit
alle rumgespammt. Ninja online.
Ninja online. So richtig hängen geblieben
so. Weißt du? Dass alle jetzt auf den Channel
gehen und feststellen. Oh nein. Er ist doch nicht online.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Der hat exklusiv
bei Mixer unterschrieben. Der wird nicht online
sein auf Twitch. Linux Mint
hat jetzt ein Update bekommen.
Wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Der letzte Stream, den fanden
die Leute ja echt nicht schlecht. Wo wir
uns ein paar Linux-Einsteiger
Distributionen angeguckt haben.
Wo ich sagen muss,
ich find immer noch,
die Elementary OS Oberfläche
war wirklich
für Linux-Verhältnisse
sehr nice.
Wie gut man damit arbeiten kann,
weiß ich nicht. Also ich
eher nicht. Ich bin ja jemand, der total
an Tastatur-Bedienung
gewöhnt ist.
Also dass ich da oben klicke, liegt einzeln
allein daran, dass ich eben gerade in Windows
gewesen bin die ganze Zeit.
Aber ansonsten bediene ich das ja
alles nur mit Tastatur.
Ups.
Schon mal einen Hackintosh aufgesetzt.
Ne, das einzige, was ich in der Richtung gemacht
hab, ist Mac OS
mal in der VM installiert.
Das hat gewisse Überschneidungen.
Weil,
VMWare erlaubt das standardmäßig nicht
unter Windows
Mac zu installieren. Guck, wenn du hier sagst
ähm,
New Virtual Machine, bla bla.
Du hast kein
naja,
du hast hier halt kein Mac
zur Auswahl.
Man kann das ändern.
Es gibt einen Patch für
VMWare Workstation.
Oder man kann das auch mit dem Hex-Editor selbst machen.
Und
dann kann man
auch Mac OS auswählen.
Allerdings kann man es danach nicht installieren, weil die offizielle
ISO, selbst wenn man die hat,
das ist ja auch schon ein Riesenakt, überhaupt
eine Mac OS ISO zu bekommen.
Ähm,
da muss man sich dann erst einmal, wie ging,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ging das nochmal, musste ich irgendwie
einen iTunes-Account machen und dann runterladen.
Total, total wir auf jeden Fall.
Und
dann musstest du irgendwie so einen speziellen
Bootloader präparieren
und so, dass du es in der VM installieren kannst.
Fuck.
Was war das denn jetzt, äh?
Oh megaloll.
Äh, welche VMWare Workstation Version
ist gerade aktuell? 15.
Außer
16 ist gerade rausgekommen.
Aber ich glaube 15.
15.
Wie sieht es mit 16 eigentlich aus?
Gibt's noch nicht.
Gib Mac OS. Alter.
Digga.
Gib Mac OS.
Find ich gut.
Das ist ein guter Name.
Gib Mac OS.
Hey.
Ich müsste es mal wieder ausprobieren.
Wir könnten das tatsächlich mal
on Stream ausprobieren.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
VMWare, Mac OS.
Die Sache ist die, ich weiß halt nicht,
wie MonkaTOS-mäßig das ist.
Ob da Twitch was dagegen hat.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich meine, es ist immerhin Amazon.
Was juckt Amazon, ob ich
Mac OS in der VM installiere?
Was Amazon für ein Ding ist.
Was Amazon viel eher jucken würde, glaube ich, ist,
wenn ich on Stream zeigen würde, wie man
die aktuellen Fire-Tablets routet und flasht
mit einem Custom-ROM.
Weil damit Amazon ja eigentlich hofft, Geld zu verdienen.
Mit Werbung und Einblendung und sonst was.
Und die hast du ja halt nicht mehr
mit einem Custom-ROM.
Ich glaube, da hätte Amazon oder Twitch was dagegen,
wenn ich das on Stream zeige.
Ja, du kannst alle
aktuellen Fire-HD
mittlerweile routen.
Und du hast sogar
für, ich glaube, mittlerweile für alle
sogar einen Custom-ROM.
Tanzverbot wurde perma gebannt, weil er
im Stream Sony Vegas gecrackt hat.
Ja, das ist ja auch bescheuert.
Aber der ist bestimmt wieder da, oder?
Das war doch bestimmt nur so ein 3-Tage-Ban.
Ja, aber
Mago United Gaming,
ich würde warten, bis
entweder hast du dir halt
gerade beim letzten Prime-Day schon welche gekauft
oder ich würde bis Weihnachten warten,
weil da sind die Dinge halt übelst billig.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob sie sich
dann auch routen lassen,
falls bis dahin nicht was Neues
raus ist.
Also, wenn ich im Stream
quasi
also, wenn der
sich einen Crack im Stream runterlädt
und das anwendet,
dann kann ich verstehen, dass man gebannt wird.
Dass Temp gebannt wird.
Hast du schon richtiges Gameplay vom
neuen Cod eingeguckt? Nur ganz kurz, das machen wir
morgen im Stream. Erstens sind
samstags mehr Leute da, freitagabend
ist es immer ein bisschen
ein bisschen weh.
Geht nicht los.
Und da muss ich auch eine andere Kategorie
einstellen.
Aber also, wenn sie mal live
on Stream einen Crack runterladen und so verwende ich
schon nicht so
nicht so big brain.
Ja, aber zu
zeigen, wie man wie man ein Tablet routet
oder einen oder Mac
in Mac OS in einer VM installiert, ist
ja was anderes.
Da umgeht man ja quasi nicht den Kopierschutz von
einer 500 Euro teuren Software.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, bei den
Amazon Tablets wäre ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Ich glaube, das zeige ich lieber nicht
on Stream, wie man Amazon Tablets flasht.
Aber Mac in einer VM installieren
könnte man mal machen.
Allerdings muss man sagen, Mac in einer
VM ist kacke.
Weil er hat keinen 3D Treiber und Mac OS ohne
3D Beschleunigung kannst du kaum verwenden.
Das ist einfach rumgeruckelt pur.
Also Mac OS in einer VM, der lohnt sich eigentlich
so gut wie gar nicht.
Dann würde ich lieber.
Das auf einer alten Hardware installieren.
Übrigens stimmt gar nicht, was ich eben gesagt habe,
dass ich das noch nie gemacht habe.
Ich habe das mal auf einer alten Hardware installiert.
Die liegt nämlich gerade unterm Stuhl sehe ich da.
Also links hier unter meinem Druckerstuhl.
So eine olle Celeron Box mit Nvidia Grafikkarte ist das.
Ja, mit GPU passt du, wird das funktionieren.
Allerdings GPU passt du, kannst du halt nicht unter
VMware Workstation unter Windows machen.
Oder auch nicht mit VMware Workstation oder Linux.
Ja.
Nee, nee, floh müsst ihr nicht.
Das wäre eher kontraproduktiv.
Der Song Request, what the fuck, Alter.
Das ist dämlich.
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Am gleichen Tag Geburtstag wie Rainer Winkler, ist das so?
Na gut, man kann sich das ja nicht aussuchen.
Und die Schleimhaut.
Und die Chancen, dass noch sehr viele andere am 2.
August Geburtstag haben, ist verdammt hoch.
Alles gut, blutpackt, pack 81.
Sogar drei Leute der Arbeit haben Geburtstag am gleichen Tag gehabt.
Also bei uns quasi Büro und Büro nebendran, drei Leute.
Also Mango United Gaming, ich habe keine Ahnung, was Leute
daran so interessant finden, dass dieser Sache zu folgen.
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Man kann.
Kann ja super interessant sein, aber ich verstehe nicht, was daran so interessant ist.
Er macht nicht den hellsten Eindruck.
Allerdings, was die Leute teilweise abziehen, macht auch nicht den hellsten Eindruck.
Nacho Libre schreibt, habe heute meine Übernahmestelle sicher bekommen.
Nice.
Heißt das nach der Ausbildung, dass du weitermachen kannst, da?
Ja, als Java Entwickler.
Oh je.
Hast du das gut überlegt?
Ja.
Also Silent Paint, die Copy-Pasta geht, glaube ich, anders, die sieht nicht so richtig formatiert
aus.
Vielleicht liegt das aber auch daran, dass ich die Schriftgröße in meinem Browserfenster
verstellt habe und sie deswegen nicht funktioniert.
Nee, nee, aber ist nice, dass sie dich übernommen haben, ne?
Also wenn dir Java Spaß macht, wer bin ich da jetzt, was dagegen zu sagen?
Aber ihr wisst ja alle, Java ist nicht meins.
Was macht ihr denn in Java?
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Business Backend Geschichten.
Ja, ich weiß.
Irgendwelche internen, oder na gut, müssen nicht interne Sachen sein, aber wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Backend Geschichten, denke ich mal.
Es gab jetzt ja die Frage auf Twitter letztens, weil wir es gerade von Java haben, Dinge,
vor denen ich Angst habe, da gibt es bei mir eindeutig solche drei Sachen, ne.
Oh, Donation.
0690, happy birthday to you.
Ja.
Kilo und Tage, 5 Euro.
Pock.
Easy money, easy life.
Ayaya, genau.
Ayaya to you.
Eine Telekom-Webseite.
Was ist das denn?
Ach, das ist da, wo man seinen Stand nachgucken kann, ne?
Wo man sein Volumen verbraucht und so nachgucken kann im Monat, oder?
Kannst du Anxiety aussprechen?
Anxiety.
Ja.
Kennst du den JFridayreplierter?
Nö.
Der, der sagt, er hat keine Anxiety.
Ja.
Ich meine, ich habe angefangen damals mit Call of Duty, YouTube-Video-Geschichten, 2010.
Guck mal, das ist fast 10 Jahre her jetzt.
9 Jahre, ziemlich genau 9 Jahre.
Es ist ja nächstes Jahr 10 Jahre.
Das ging schnell.
Da war ich 25, 24.
Was ist deine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache?
Halbe, halbe.
Das ist C Sharp und Ruby.
So beides.
Ungefähr, ungefähr gleich auf.
Leider ist Ruby nicht mehr angesagt.
Ruby ist outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Das war mal vor 10 Jahren übelst im Hype, als alle der Meinung waren, oder sogar noch länger, das ist noch länger her,
wo alle der Meinung waren, sie machen jetzt geiles Zeug in Ruby on Rails.
War ja damals voll der Hype.
Aber jetzt macht das keiner mehr.
Jetzt verwendet das eigentlich keiner mehr.
Heute werden die Leute bemitleidet, die altes Ruby on Rails Zeug supporten müssen.
GitLab ist auf Ruby Basis, ja.
GitLab ist Ruby on Rails.
Aber GitLab gibt es halt auch schon eine Weile.
Aber das war damals schon nicht mehr der heiße Shit als GitLab.
Und GitLab gibt es jetzt ja auch schon irgendwie 7 Jahre oder so.
Aber selbst damals war Ruby on Rails nicht mehr der heiße Shit.
Es gibt noch viele Sachen, die in Ruby...
Guck mal, Twitter.
Twitter hat auch mit Ruby angefangen.
Und ich glaube, ich glaube, dass GitHub selbst sogar intern noch vieles auf Ruby hat.
Ja, wenn es danach geht, kannst du auch COBOL programmieren.
Da kriegst du auch für Legacy-Sachen übelst Geld.
Gehst du vor 3 Beta?
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Naja Leute, ich gehe jetzt mal gucken, wo meine Katze steckt.
Da kriegt die jetzt nämlich noch was hingestellt für heute Nacht.
Dass sie mir nicht auf den Keks geht.
Dann gehe ich pennen.
Ja.
Da liegt sie.
Guckt mir zu.
Twitch Panel HTML.
Was?
Ist das eine ARD nebenbei?
Das ist nicht Monkatos?
Assembling New 3D Printer.
Von den Farben her sieht es aus wie so ein Prusa Printer, oder?
Wer sich damit auch schon ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ach, tatsächlich, ich habe ja sogar ein Video aufgenommen in der Gears of War-Beta.
POG.
Stimmt, warum hat er da eigentlich ein Thermal... äh, eine Hitze an, sieh wozu.
Ich will da gucken, ob seine Hände noch wärmer sind als der 3D-Drucker.
So, falls ihr noch was zu besprechen gibt, haut raus, ne?
Wenn es noch irgendwas Interessantes gibt, bin ich schon ein paar Minuten da, ansonsten
gehe ich jetzt pennen.
Pirate Software, klingt schon so nach Sicherheitskopie.
Äh, Stack Overflow Survey machen wir das nächste Mal, da kann ich mehr dazu sagen.
Kannst du das nächste Mal nochmal reinhauen in den Chat, falls ich vergessen sollte.
Das machen wir das nächste Mal.
Cannabis 24 im Hip-Hop, Lofi-Hip-Hop, was es für Streams alles gibt, kann man zugucken,
wie es wächst.
Business-App-Design, Business-Apps sind langweilig.
Relax with...
Ja, was es alles für Channels gibt.
Kann man sich die Schafe angucken und die Hühner, warum?
Und wenn man cheert, fällt Futter raus für die Schafe.
Cute Cheap, was es alles gibt.
3D-MMO, Rust, wann geht der Stream morgen los?
Ja, wenn ich ausgeschlafen habe und wenn ich eventuell noch einkaufen gewesen bin, keine
Ahnung, wahrscheinlich Nachmittag oder so.
Natürlich in Wim, ja was sonst?
Was sonst, ja, bin schon dann richtig hardcore gewimpt.
Der Wasserkühlungs-Tool sieht nicht so glücklich aus, als wäre es kaputt gegangen irgendwie.
Ja, oder auch nicht.
Was haben wir denn sonst hier für solche Streams, ich sag auch immer, Wim ist komplett
viel zu viel.
AWK und Seed, Echo, AWK und Seed.
Mehr braucht man nicht.
175 Beats per Minute, das ist Dance-Stream, ne das ist, das ist Musik-Dance, Dance-Musik-DJ-Stream.
Was es mittlerweile alles auf Twitch gibt.
Schau mal, ob du jemanden aus alten YouTube-Zeiten zu posten findest.
Es ist so voll hier auf Twitch, da findest du überhaupt keinen.
Wenn du nicht zufällig, wenn du nicht zufällig gerade da drüber stolperst.
Einfaches 3D-Modelling, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist echt cool.
Keine Ahnung.
Kenn ich mich nicht mit aus.
Ich kenn bloß Blender.
Also von kostenlosen Sachen.
Das Grill ist am streamen.
Aha.
Okay, wir scrollen jetzt mal ganz runter.
Wann war das gerade, ja.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich hab da gerade irgendeinen, irgendeinen Avatar gesehen, der mir bekannt
vorkommt.
Ich hab da gerade irgendeinen Avatar gesehen, der mir bekannt vorkommt.
Ja, ihn hier, genau.
Und ihn.
Den kann, den.
Und der sagt mir auch noch was vom Namen her.
Ja, machs gut, Flo96.
Egal, was alles so gibt auf Twitch.
Ich scroll jetzt mal ganz runter, Leute, die keine Views haben.
Boah, wie viele, wie viele, wie viele mittlerweile da streamen, ey.
Meine Güte.
Der Sander hatte ich mal gegrüßt in einem Video von ihm.
Was, echt?
In einem der letzten oder was?
Oder in dem alten?
Weil das alte kenne ich natürlich.
Ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt bei ihm.
Boah, wie viele Leute streamen.
Wahnsinn, ey.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Drei Wochen her.
Hab ich gar nicht gesehen, aber cool, ja.
Übrigens, das ist auch sowas, warum Endlos-Scroll suckt, ne.
Die Seite wird einfach übertrieben lahm, wenn's zu lang ist.
Warum muss sowas Endlos-Scroll sein?
Warum kann ich nicht, warum gibt es hier keinen Button?
Einfach auf letzte Seite springen.
Ich mein, ich kann Low-to-High machen, aber warum gibt es da keinen Button?
Das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist
doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch,
das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist
das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das
ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist
doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch,
das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das
ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist
doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch, das ist doch,
nicht warum gibt es hier keinen button einfach auf letzte seite springen ich
möchte kein low to high machen aber warum gibt es da kein button das doch
müll oder 3d printer ist der letzte stream fortnight fortnight fortnight
fortnight alles mit null viewer ab wann kommen die
einen wie die einen viewer wie viele leute mit null viewer guck mal da gibt's
da gibt es hundert seiten gefühlt voll mit null viewer warum streamt man mit null
viewer ja wahrscheinlich dass man nicht immer auf null viewer bleibt heftig
tja leider dank endless scroll können wir uns das jetzt nicht angucken wann der
erste kommt mit einem viewer weil mein browser sonst abkackt da braucht er schon
nur drei gigabyte oder so na gut leute ich mach schluss wir sehen uns morgen
danke schön dass ihr dran bis morgen tschüss